[Music]
you made it weird with pete holmes
what's happening weirdos this is my
conversation with pete davis an
incredible fellow and author he wrote
the book i want to make sure i get the
title right here dedicated i knew that
but the case for commitment in an age of
infinite browsing this is a topic that i
am very very passionate about and very
interested in and i'm so glad that pete
could come on and illuminate uh some of
those some of those uh lesser lesser
extolled virtues i'm going to say
extolled
virtues up top
i am doing a live just a couple things
to plug up top my live largo show if you
want to come see me do stand up just go
to largo dash la.com and look on the
calendar for pete holmes living at largo
uh i think this airs before so september
12th uh sorry july
12th
is that right july 12th is the next one
always always always an incredible show
be sure to check out dedicated by pete
davis as well not pete davidson pete
davis and if you like the show why not
try a pete's pick like our friends at
ritual ritual makes my favorite mail
order multivitamin it comes in the mail
i take it every single day i love it
because i can take it on an empty
stomach and it doesn't upset my stomach
because these pills that they make are
time released so they wait until they
get into your lower intestine before
they break down i do intermittent
fasting so that is super important for
me to take a vitamin that not only
doesn't affect my fast but won't make me
feel sick because sometimes vitamins on
an empty stomach will make you feel sick
it's also the only multivitamin i've
ever taken that doesn't make my pee look
like predator blood it doesn't like give
you highlighter pee they also make
symbiotic plus which is the world's best
in my opinion prebiotic it's got
prebiotic postbiotics and i always get
this wrong and probiotics of course
prebiotics probiotics and postbiotics to
support a balanced gut microbiome
synbiotic plus is really a three in one
probiotic gut health is so so so
important not only for digestion not
only for elimination but also they're
saying there's more and more data that
says our gut is basically like a second
brain so i take my gut health super
super seriously
and i'm so glad that ritual is making
one now because the symbiotic plus is
not only the best one that i've ever
taken but it doesn't gunk up the works
there's a few uh pre-post and probiotics
that i've taken in the past that shut
the whole system down
synbiotic plus in my experience gets
everything working just right in a
single nested minty capsule that's one
daily capsule that you do not need to
refrigerate which i think is so
incredible
it's designed to thrive it's a delayed
release capsule designed to help reach
the colon not the stomach which is the
ideal place for probiotics to survive
and throw
and grow excuse me they're designed with
moisture controlled bottle technology to
protect the probiotic strains which
means you don't have to keep them in the
fridge in fact a lot of the probiotics
that you see that are in the
refrigerated section of the grocery
store the reason they're in the fridge
is because they're too fragile to
survive any condition so
they're not going to make it home is
what i'm saying you want ones that you
can keep in the cupboard so symbiotic
plus and ritual are here to help
celebrate not hide your insides there's
no shame in your gut game and that's why
ritual is offering weirdos 10 off during
your first three months visit ritual.com
weird to start your ritual today or add
symbiotic plus to your subscription
today just like val and i have they have
the most two of the world's most studied
strains with over 350 publications of
human clinical trials these are the best
uh probiotics that i've ever found give
them a try show your support of this
podcast i'll get into it also
we are brought to us by our friends at
living libations you guys know this we
are a living libations family the holmes
cheney family the household i've been
for many years very careful about what i
put in my body when it comes to what i
eat and what i drink but i noticed i
wasn't being very careful about what i
put on my body i was buying shaving
creams and face washes that i thought
were fancy and good because i bought
them at a mall kiosk and they had a
french name and they were expensive but
of course these chemicals are made by
corporations that don't give a [__]
about you and they're filled with
toxicity levels and chemicals that are
linked to disease these things were
never intended for the human body and of
course what you put on your body gets
into your body i want to eat food where
i recognize the ingredients and i of
course now want my skin tick care to be
the same enter living libations they've
completely rehauled every product this
is a great way to support the show by
the way if you have something that you
use every day i promise you living
libations has a high-end and natural
replacement for the random chemical
nightmare you may be buying at the
pharmacy for example every morning lilo
before she goes to preschool we cover
her in sunscreen a lot of sunscreens
that you see even on amazon or whatever
that say they're natural they're not
they're just doing slightly better than
the more chemically ones but if you want
a truly truly natural zinc based
sunscreen that you can feel good about
slathering on your baby's sensitive skin
every day get the love the sun sunscreen
from living libations if you want to do
what i do i'd use their ginger
exfoliating scrub which is not only made
with ingredients that i recognize as
natural and real but it's also the most
badass exfoliant i've ever used in my
life made with plants and oils and
extracts that i recognize and zen shave
is what i use to shave it's a shaving
balm that is so clean and so pure that
you can actually use a dab of it to rub
on your skin as aftershave afterwards
that's how clean and pure and great it
is and at night both val and i put the
best skin ever moisturizer on our skin
smells great gets your skin feeling
great keeps your skin looking great
before bed but this is a great way to
support the show like i said whether you
need something big or something small
just go to
livinglibations.com and use promo code
this is different every month so it's we
love weird the first letter is capital
we capital love capital weird capital uh
you'll get 15 off anything you find on
that website and show your support of
the show and do your body your teeth
your hair your skin your eyes do them
all a favor while showing some support
we really appreciate it and thank you
living libations all right everybody
enjoy my chat with pete davis be sure to
check out dedicated his incredible book
i love this conversation i hope you do
too
get
into it
you do not have you're on this couch
great question well if i've heard that
although it might freak out she's very
special well this is the first couch i
told val i love you on actually
because this couch used to be
in my apartment
get rid of it
well yeah no well we started doing video
and we're like well we shouldn't we
shouldn't record on that same old dumpy
couch and i was like but it's i can't
also i get locked up like if if you make
it too complicated to go where you want
to go
bring the show to youtube and then you
go well to do that you need to get rid
of the couch okay put in a table yeah
build in mics all that stuff i just
won't do it i'll go like [__] off but if
you just go like i think you can just
shoot it how we've always been doing it
beautiful right yeah it's almost on
theme with your book
that's great there's something to tie
back to dedicated i'm not exactly sure
no yeah no we got a standpoint yeah
no i actually
feel for you man doing my my research
which was a joy because i love your your
yeah
message
i love your message
but i i also recognize that like you're
doing
a lot of press or you have done in the
past year a lot of press for this show i
was going to tell you this is this
interview is a special it's a it's a
special
thing in my journey with this book tell
me everything
do you want to scoot get your only if
you want to i want you to be comfortable
that looks more comfortable than what
you were doing
you were like bad seat vegas show
for a second this is great yeah so don't
tell me why here's my journey um i love
it you know about the wheel of desire
the hedonic treadmill you know
there's also the wheel of samsara
there's something i don't know what
you're talking about the tr yeah that
you know you want something you get it
and then you want something else
yeah dana carvey who did not sit here he
was in the old studio but he said beware
of empty room syndrome and i said what's
that he said you buy a bigger house now
you have more rooms and you have to fill
them yes no so i've i've had this
feeling you know i i was like
blogging and writing magazine articles
and i dreamed of having a book i was
like one day five years from now i'll
i'll get to the amount of twitter
followers i need to have a book and then
i buy this total what is that number by
the way i don't what are you thinking i
don't know i was curious maybe somebody
told you the number and i was you know i
was just like oh okay i'll be on my
grind for five years yeah and then by
this total miracle
of uh of some random rise and grind
facebook page right
facebook yeah yeah yeah repo re-cut up
my speech took out all the boring parts
added inspirational music behind it and
that's what the internet does yes
the internet trims the fat
and makes it uh exactly what it uh you
know exactly what it is consumer this by
the way sorry to interject but i'd like
to draw this out as long as i can
because it's so natural and easy to talk
about this but i was just talking to
somebody today about like carl young has
speeches like read by alan watts but
like on youtube for all of the like
you know attention deficit instagram
depression whatever it might be like the
negative side of the internet people are
able to find alan watts reading a carl
junction that's amazing yeah there are
good things i'm not i'm not an anti i
know you know it was a beautiful well
it's made my that's why i'm here on this
couch somebody
took your
harvard speech did you go to harvard
yeah harvard college or yeah and then
law school yeah i'm one of those loving
people
that's so fun
you know i'm from that area oh okay yeah
so i used to hang out in the pit this is
my claim i love the pit it's like i hung
out in oxford england i didn't go to
oxford but i was like at the coffee i
was at the bird and baby it's actually a
pub in oxford i'm very proud that i came
up with that but i know that area we
probably went to some of the same pizza
places oh i love it oh yeah and no folks
yeah yeah i used to go to pinocchio's
all the time yes unbelievable stuff this
is the thing i've only appreciated in
retrospect because you know you're in
college you're focused on all the
college things yeah and then i was like
oh wait i spent eight years of my life
in a very cool city and i didn't
appreciate it enough and in a new room
even if the school wasn't there if it'd
be well the school's not the cool part
of it it's the city itself i actually
think the presence of harvard keeps
everybody on their best people there
really is something
even the unhoused people are kind of
like hello there's something kind of
there's something sort of harvard about
the whole and i love walking around the
campus once i realized that you could
walk around harvard and like nobody
knows if you get in like if you can get
i can't remember if they locked the gate
they didn't oh no no they don't you just
walk through yes just act like you
belong here i i have this funny i'll get
back to my main thing i will bring it
that's my job don't worry about that
but my favorite thing about i actually
have the inverse feeling about harvard
which is the awful part about harvard is
the
the striving the meritocracy the
like obsession with career well this is
the best of the best and now they have
to differentiate themselves yeah totally
that's a total uh inside place but the
best part is the old
fogey college you know the like they're
like we get crazy dressed up at the
graduation and we have these old
professors that say you know in these
buildings in 1748 which is why you asked
who sat here um and so um i actually got
a kick out of this is where mark
zuckerberg
took a golden turd and said i can charge
millions for people to get a whiff uh
yeah no i i i'm intimidated and
impressed by harvard university i
actually would like to step that out a
little bit but tell me finish your thing
yeah so i was on this is i'm telling you
why this is a specialty um
the you know i had these i i got really
lucky and i got to have a book five
years before you know 10 years or i
never would have had a book but i got
this miracle thing because of the speech
and how it got why did they ask you to
do this speech i won the speech contest
and you wrote it i wrote it yeah and
they read it and they read it so you
talk about a meritocracy it wasn't like
you're the the uncle or the i don't know
but then it's like what does it mean
that you won this they're like oh it was
a ruffle too many feathers or something
because it's a thing everyone can
get behind i know what you mean it needs
to be a little across the plate yes but
your speech is saying something i i just
feel i i'm i still stand but you know
after the journey of the speech in this
book i still stand by it yeah i was
preparing for this interview by
listening to the first chapter again and
it's oh did you ever listen back to i
watched it you're like who is that
person that oh yeah how do i get back
into that
like when i do a show sometimes i'll
listen to my old records and be like oh
they want this guy because there's all
the different facets of your personality
you're like they seem to want this one
and i'll be that one i guess as i get
older that guy changes more and more yes
so i have to refresh my memory
absolutely yeah so you were okay you
listen so i get this and then i i have
this a total dream you get you celebrate
the total dream happening you get to
write a book and then slowly the wheel
of desire
comes in and it's like oh wait i kinda
i'd like this book to be successful yeah
and then um you know zac artillery by
the way you got your dreams
about the choir here no no i'm saying
for everybody like he's so right he says
you got your house you got your dream
house and then you worry that your house
will burn down yes he's right it never
ends and then i'm like i want it to be
reviewed that's my thing and then it
gets reviewed and then i hear
oh you know that newspaper actually
reviews has done two reviews before
like oh wait why did i only get one
review and then i you know i'm getting
on the wheel of desire and this totally
joyful thing that is a total miracle
that i get to get to do and get to share
this idea i've been
you know burbling in my heart for 10
years with the world i get to come on
this yeah um
it has led to a lot of like wheel of
desire pain and so i decided when i when
you said i should come on the show i
said this will be my final
thing it will not be a means to an end
it will be an end in itself pete for its
own sake for its own sake and so i don't
even care i i i'm sounding fake but this
is totally real i don't care if i sell a
book from this yeah i'm just enjoying
that i'm in los angeles yes i'm in here
sitting on this couch i'm talking with
you yes if you hear me and you think i
don't like that guy that's okay yeah and
so i'm this is i'm trying to have i'm
getting off the exit ramp after this
interview well i'm really glad that you
said that because it is one of the uh
biggest interests of my life i i mark
duplass and i were on the phone
two days ago and we were talking about
for its own sake we were talking about
ideas and we're like can we just enjoy
this phone call where we talk about
ideas and maybe nothing ever happens
with any of these ideas and that's what
this is usually we wait till the god
part to go like just this i said i did a
show last night and i said to them
and go stop acting like there's
something after this yeah like
you could get more of it and say like
imagine the conversation we would have
if when you walk out let's not say you
die but you just fall into an
abyss and all of reality is over it's
not as personal as you die it just it
all ends here
it just you suddenly the
dust in the air is visible to you and
you really drop into the moment and
that's super important so i'm glad that
you're that you made that intention and
i think it makes a difference yes i
think you're just going to enjoy this
i'm dead as well so let's see if that
let's see if i can do that and of course
i mean that is that is the drama of this
this
that's the stage we'll check back at the
end but i actually think and tell me
what you think that the paradox is if
you try and sell your book people don't
want your book yes yeah i mean maybe
maybe some people it's like selling
knives or something you can cut a penny
with the shears and that's a certain
type of sales but there's another type
of sales the non-desperate non-sweaty
non-ham-handed guy
that and and this is what i did when i
was trying to sell my book i know that
sounds like i was trying machiavelli and
like i was trying to trick them but i
would just try to remember what like
doing comedy
what made me laugh the first time i
thought this thought that's when i think
what i'm telling a joke when i was
talking about my book i tried to
reconnect to the part of me that wanted
to write it in the first place yes which
was you yeah
noticing
i had two things i wanted to load you
with okay uh one is
um
buddha
by the way i think it's like 90 percent
of quotes attributed to the buddha
siddhartha uh are not buddha quotes yeah
that's just a fun fact so this is
probably not buddha the mark twain of
yes a thousand examples of years ago
precisely
and native americans suffer the same
fate unfortunately a lot of things that
are just kind of like general and wise
it just gets under the umbrella so many
tribes so many peoples but they're just
like native american wisdom i i learned
that from people calling me out from
doing it frankly but anyway apparently
the buddha said if you want to hit water
don't dig six one foot wells dick dig
one six foot well amen and isn't that i
mean i i just wanted to put nobody's
come at you that way but is
yes but let's step it out a little bit
because i listened to your speech
obviously again before this morning and
i loved it and and it's right you were
absolutely right when we started talking
that is exactly in line with what this
show is about
uh which is
figuring out a different way to look at
reality yeah and there seems to be a way
that
i hate to be conspiratorial but they
meaning
uh the media machine the social media
television media even movies and culture
yeah seems to tell you that more is
better yeah
faster is better yeah um online dating
has to be something that you think a lot
about yeah totally i mentioned in the
book yeah it is
like infinite browsing mode what a thing
yeah that's what that's what is kind of
the antagonist of the book but um yeah i
don't want it to be the total antagonist
because well browsing is not an
antagonist but infinite browsing is
right and one of the great examples of
that is what happens when you just
browse through people tell us over again
because i've heard i'm going to tell you
what i've heard but i'm not buttering
your bread you are the expert
i've heard that people when you know and
the apps are designed that you might
even match with somebody and you start
dating and like three months in they
have the science like when to ping you
and be like hey a lot of people are
looking at your profile so there's money
to be made in keeping you browsing right
yeah totally don't sell a guy one car
sell five cars over five years right now
and tell them you have the problem and
give the solution exactly any in the
solution telling them you keep having
the problem create the problem
that is one of the most this is why i'm
so excited to be talking to you it's one
of the most [__] up things in the
world how did we get to a place where
part of humanity is this section of
humanity figures out how to tell this
section of humanity they're not happy so
they can sell them something that they
never needed
it's insane yeah no totally including
partners
amen you know and it's you know i the
thing i always like to say
in this is that
browsing you know that so the the the
message of the book is is the the joy of
commitment
as opposed to the the pain and that
comes from infinite browsing i
completely the long-term joy of the pair
over the short-term safety and comfort
of browsing absolutely and
i always like giving browsing at stu
which is what do people like about
browsing okay one is they like the
flexibility oh if this doesn't work i
can always break up i can always quit i
can always do something else i can
always move somewhere else yes
there's a really beautiful part about
browsing that i really want to honor
well you must run into this like
cultures where there's arranged marriage
cultures where there's um there aren't
really as many anymore but cast some
systems oh totally like my name is
holmes that means we were homemakers
like we built homes yeah you have to be
you inherit a trade who wants to be the
you know you have to be the job that
your parent had yeah
smith you were a blacksmith yes like it
wasn't just a smitty it wasn't smitty it
was your job
and there's a quality to that there was
a there's a happiness tied to that
extreme
lack of choice which is maybe what
you're talking about yeah but we've
rebelled so far into what i call no one
tells me what to do this is like a total
pendulum book it's not like one thing is
good and the other is bad it's just like
i'm noticing we gotta turn the dial
notice this is a very good way to turn
the dial a little bit back because
people don't want you to take away their
it's like the illusion of freedom yes
would you say so keep on the dating
thing okay so there's like flexibility
you don't you don't want to marry the
person if they're not right for you you
want to be open to change it
there's a really beautiful part of
browsing which i i call the authenticity
that comes from browsing by jumping from
thing to thing you find the thing that
sparks your art yes you find the thing
that inspires you you find the thing
that makes you alive it won't
necessarily very likely won't be the
first thing right so um and then the
third kind of shallow one is uh it's
just fun browsing you know which is you
know that's an important thing to have
part of your life is to just have fun
jumping from the novelty but now if you
say in your book that we have more
access to more like it's sort of weird
but most of us have seen a guy with a
beard of bees there was there was a time
that you would hear the carnival sit
down and you'd take a two and a half day
journey to see the guy with the bearded
beast but we can all see it you can
google image search safe sir jobs guys
and then you see pubes of bees you see
uh you know the fine
uh hair on your butt of these i love
this i'm obsessed i had to put into the
book because and all my friends are like
laughed at me when i put in the book
because i'm like obsessed with this
quote by mark zuckerberg where he said
he wrote a letter to his son as like
some pr gimmick for facebook at one
point and he said my hope is when you
grow up
you can have a thousand times as many
experiences
as people before you were able to have
and i just thought that was the weirdest
it's like the weirdest creepiest thing a
thousand times as many experiences but
that's what i think the novelty is it's
like the dream of we could have a
thousand times as many experiences
that's the problem
and
this is what we're talking about
if you're able to like clear your head
enough to do almost anything
fully yeah val and i were in new york
city you can do anything in new york
city that's sort of the fun of it it's
it's like living in the internet but we
went into the park and we sat under a
tree and we just were deliberately
didn't have anything that didn't had one
experience we had one experience but one
experience lived fully
that's a memory there have been days
that i've packed with a million things
and i mean little trite things i don't
mean hikes up to views those tend to
stick with us but like when you're just
gorging on micro moments like you said
in netflix like you you can't even pick
a movie you get exhausted trying to pick
a movie so you know you don't even watch
a movie we all know that feeling but we
so few of us seems to know
the joy of of commitment i mean totally
totally cause all of those
things i mentioned they all curdle over
time i like i you know it doesn't have
to be in your 20s but i like talking
about like the beginning of the sweaties
those are very exciting by the end of
your 20s or the proverbial 20s whatever
like different acts in your life and
chapters in your life yeah those
20s do go into
i didn't have my 20s until my thirties
yeah some people have their fifties you
know
yeah um but my dad's roughly seventeen
i'm just kidding but yeah
they curdle into like darker things so
you know the the flexibility i say on
the book turtles and uh uh choice
paralysis
you jump from thing the thing that you
no longer have the capacity to even
choose anything because you're so scared
that you're gonna choose the wrong thing
because you know there's all these
things that happens on the dating apps
all the time i hear from people which is
you know i've seen nine different guys
and you know how could i know this guy
is gonna be worse on some qualities as
one of the nine guys because i'm making
a frankenstein guy or gallery right
right um in my head of the best
qualities of the nine people i already
swiped through or went on quick dates
with that i can't even choose anyone
anymore that's troubling that's scary
yeah
the authenticity eventually you know if
it's all about finding what is
individually the true me very good thing
to search for but if you infinitely
search for the true you
eventually you have what emil durkheim
the french sociologist called anime
which is like this kind of spiritual
isolation
where you
have no connections to anything because
nothing perfectly fit you you have no
institution that you're loyal to you
have no relationship that you're loyal
to you have no place you're part of and
you uh you don't have anything to orient
you at all yes and then the the novelty
curdles into shallowness you feel you
feel like i've done a thousand things
and i remember none of it
which is absolutely
i mean i remember tony robbins he has
this philosophy that he's like rocking
chair moments he's like when you're when
you're old and you're in your rocking
chair and you look back on your life and
you'll be like man i i was on that
zeppelin or whatever
and i i'd love to have him on the show
and talk to him about it because in my
experience that's not really how reality
works
it's really just how you feel now and
your past is sort of an accumulation
that leads potentially maybe to your
feeling but here's something i think
more interesting as you were saying
a lot of it seems to be in service of
this phantom which is your what in the
religious tradition you call your false
self or you might call it your ego and
it's really in flux it's not really a
real thing like 22 year old pete had
different preferences than 32 year old
people and 42 year old pete so when
you're looking for the perfect partner
that meets the desires of 22 year old
you
there's no move and there's no
surrendering to the flow and the
beautiful chaos of life if that makes
sense you're looking at it as a binary
like he likes hikes he doesn't eat dairy
or whatever it might be and then later
in life
what i'm saying is
we're not
uh s.a.t bubbles yes totally we're not
there's not some you out there that you
must perfectly fine and you get the
alert back
no wrong you right
that's yes you found it it's more about
cultivating a relationship to the
ever-changing state of reality wouldn't
you agree totally well there's this
great i love this bob dylan quota it's
like it brings it a lot to me do it in
the voice i'll do it in the voice he
goes he gets he gets asked by a reporter
his best quotes are when he's like
interviewed oh cause he's upset because
yeah
he doesn't want to be doing it's not the
truth
he goes um
someone goes did you leave minnesota to
find yourself
did bob did you leave minnesota to find
yourself that's such a like
yeah it's the dylan did you leave
minnesota to find yourself
some reporter that's never left
minnesota
nobody finds themselves
they make themself
and what i love is like maybe it's not
make i don't know about the word make
but it's like
the self
it unfolds
through what you choose to do yes and
you know it's like when you decide i'm
going to move to texas and become a
texan and i'm going to put roots down
suddenly you become a texan that's right
when you decide to marry someone you
become the person who is their husband
or wife or whatever and when you decide
you know what i'm i'm going to go all in
on on becoming a brazilian brazilian jiu
jitsu instructor you then yourself
becomes
a brazilian jiu jitsu instructor it is
not you have found the true
cosmic self that was a brazilian jiu
jitsu that's right you're behind the
curtain you built that's why i'm saying
i i'm not putting it down with the false
self or the ego as i call it uh as many
call it it's not a phantom in the bad
way but none of those things learning
jujitsu uh fighting
was never essential to you like if you
would learn something else yes then uh
you would have become that like if i had
been born in kentucky instead of boston
i would have been from kentucky or if i
moved like these things aren't essential
so they're not real so that's why i love
bob dylan's quote you you make yourself
into whatever it is you want to be but
then unfortunately we spend too much
time defending and sort of bolstering
that identity does that make sense like
oh yeah yeah you really you mistake it
for your real you can't obsess over i've
made this choice and now that is who i
want but that's what i mean by the flow
and the beautiful chaos of reality
if you think if you lay out
your preferences on a monday i think if
you really watch yourself on a tuesday
they they might be totally different
yeah you know what i mean like usually
like what i'm saying is
reality has the potential to be so much
more surprising unexpected delightful
and again to say it again but chaotic
like you don't necessarily know who you
want to date until you date someone that
really shows you what you don't like or
what you do like but like putting it
into like the s.a.t bubbles this is a
nonsense pursuit it's the the metaphor i
keep obsessing over like organic
metaphors yeah and i like filled the
book with them gardens not engineering
yeah you know and it's so much of now
it's we've tricked ourselves into
thinking it's all science it's all
engineering it's all mechanical that's
exactly what it is it's much more i just
i don't know this is not a
it's probably not profound and i don't
even know how to back it up yet it's
just burbling in my heart which is just
we're much more like plants
than we are like a machine yeah we're
not ones and zeros
and your preferences i've said this
before i haven't said it in years but
it's like building a sand castle under
water it's always moving like you're
going like i like this and like my mood
because i have the benefit of being able
to watch my mood that's like part of my
job as an artist and represent the
different things it's constantly flexing
but then there are certain things that
i'm like
i'm all in
with valerie but valerie and i even the
way we are is that's my wife for those
of you that are just joining us uh
i think this is a radio show if you just
tuned in valerie's my wife but
we've grown and changed into things that
when we first met we wouldn't have
thought that we wanted that since that's
wild so it's more like the the the
quality of spaciousness and adaptability
is what i wanted more than somebody that
like eats what i eat or ribs for the
teams that i root for what are your top
three favorite movies get the [__] out
of your match.com
like where's the like are you adaptable
are you spacious are you clear and all
of that stuff has to do with like
internal work that there is no bubble to
fill in and you can't like put it on it
put it in words you know and you can't
sell it and you know this is i one thing
i keep i try to hammer home a lot in
messaging around commitment is
commitment is not a dead rule it's not
you know i have committed to live by
this rule and therefore
i must like beat myself up with this
idea i just it's much more of a deciding
to
enter into a relationship and having a
little stickiness and loyalty to that
relationship and participating in the
life of that relationship again just
obsessed with the organization it's
alive it changes it grows you know i
have the section on stewardship in the
book
that i i got really into the word
steward
and i said what does it mean to steward
something and so i talked to a rabbi and
i say you're stewarding this religion
it's like three thousand you know
thousands of years old you are the one
who took it from the grandparent
rabbi and you're going to pass it to the
next rabbi and hopefully you know like a
guard continues and um and they said you
know stewardship is not putting it
behind glass you know it's not putting
this religion behind glass and then
saying like we must protect it at all
cost with like guards around it it's
like
having someone hand you a baby or
something and it's like you gotta change
things you gotta adapt to it you gotta
keep it alive you gotta not make it you
gotta find what the core of it is so
that you don't fully perversely change
the core and call it what it is
but you also have to know what's not the
core and adapt to that but that's like
interpersonal relationships are like
history too history
keeps like changing and flowing what i'm
saying is reality is a is a river it's a
flow and it's and it's wild and we'd
like to tame it and change it and turn
it into a survey but it but it's not and
so that's what what i'm saying i think
what you're saying is
well tell me what you're saying because
it feels like committing to someone who
might i don't know if valerie would have
absolutely 100 percent on paper been my
person that i would have said i forgot
all others i never did internet dating
but like we grew into one another you've
heard the thing about uh arranged
marriages where they say in america they
put hot soup
on a table and let it cool down in india
they put cold soup over a fire and let
it get hot oh i've never heard that
isn't that good
i i think we we weren't arranged
obviously but we've gotten
the soup has gotten hotter and hotter as
we went but i never would have been able
to put it on a form
necessarily
pardon the interruption weirdos this
episode is brought to us by our friends
at betterhelp betterhelp knows life can
be overwhelming and many people are
burned out without even knowing it
symptoms can include lack of motivation
feeling helpless or trapped attachment
fatigue and more i know when i'm working
a little too much when i'm not taking
enough me time when i'm not being
listened to enough i mean i can really
start to run on fumes and grind to a
complete halt we are huge believers in
talk therapy on the show and i'm so glad
that better help is here we associate
burnout with work but that's not even
the only cause any of our roles in life
can lead to feeling burned out and
better help online therapy wants to
remind you to prioritize yourself
talking with someone can help you figure
out what's causing stress in your life
val and i have both had our lives
absolutely transformed by talk therapy
it's greater than the sum of its parts
you think you're just talking to
somebody but for some reason something
about the human animal being heard and
being seen by a professional can make a
world of difference and better help is
customized online therapy that offers
video phone and even live chat sessions
with your therapist so you don't have to
see anyone on camera if you don't want
to it's even more affordable than
in-person therapy and you can be matched
with a therapist in under 48 hours plus
weirdos will get 10 off their first
month at betterhelp.com
weirdo that's better h-e-l-p
betterhelp.com
weirdo
get some help we all need a little help
sometimes and show your support of this
podcast thank you to better help for
your support of the show
also for those of you who occasionally
enjoy a little nip of nicotine look
we're all adults here and i know some of
us choose to use nicotine to relax to
focus or just unwind after a long day
thankfully lucy is a modern oral
nicotine company that makes nicotine gum
losses lozenges and pouches for adults
who are looking for the best most
responsible way to consume their
nicotine why not swap it up and try a
new nicotine product that you can feel
good about i personally
occasionally enjoy a little nip of
nicotine when i'm working i do find it
helps me to focus and dial into what i'm
working on it's also just a nice little
little uppy treat that helps my mood and
makes me feel a zesty jolt i'm gonna
call it a zesty jolt
and if you enjoy using nicotine you
should definitely check out lucy's
products at lucy.co that's
lucy.co and use promo code weird at
checkout also i have to read this
disclaimer warning this product contains
nicotine nicotine is an addictive
chemical remember if you're interested
in a better way to use nicotine visit
lucy.co
and be sure to use that promo code
weird i always tell my friends who smoke
don't bring smoke into this don't bring
carbon monoxide into it you don't like
smoking you like nicotine just use
nicotine
your relationship is not your original
decision to enter into the relationship
which is another thing it is the whole
life
of the relationship you know it's and so
many people you know if you think about
someone as the one
anytime that you're having a big fight
with them you're like if you're thinking
oh it's the one and i made this proper
choice that was and you're always
thinking after the fight oh my gosh
maybe i didn't make the right choice
maybe i had the wrong information maybe
i was not thinking straight at that time
but the answer is not
to reassure you and say oh you were
making the right choice you had the
proper information no it's to say that
choice was just one part of this journey
yes and every single piece is part of
the journey yes and your challenge right
now is you're in the now now and are you
gonna are you gonna
if you feel like this thing this living
relationship is sick are you gonna heal
it if it feels like it needs to be
strengthened are you gonna strengthen it
and honestly and i say this a lot having
read a book equipment if it's truly dead
yeah are you gonna have this morbid play
acting with the dead body of your
relationship and like lose usually your
life or you can let it go yeah you know
and so um that's the question it's not
was this original choice the perfect
choice and that's that's the whole
message i'm trying to get across is
let's lower the stakes of the initial
choice of diving in yeah so that you can
dive in and have all the joys of being
part of a living thing with other people
and other things and other institutions
and places it's another way of saying
be here and and follow through and see
what happens then see what happens yeah
i'm glad you said that because it does
sound you must get that joke a lot that
people well you can't get divorced now
you wrote a book right now i think i
think about it all the time but
i think no i know i don't want to yes
but i'm just like i tell my wife all the
time i go i go
you know if i if this book does okay
that you know it's worth writing a story
on you know it would be a viral story of
the guy who wrote the commitment book
yeah you know
unfaithful or something so that's
another another thing keeping this
together well the fitness guru has a
heart attack after eating a pizza you
know that we like those sorts of ironies
or whatever yeah um tell me
a little bit more you we had a couple
irons in the fire going i like the
netflix one
i also the other survey do you want to
hear the other thing i don't tell you
i've said this many times on the show
and i might get it wrong and you might
be familiar with it so correct me but
they did it a test they had six
paintings and two groups of ten people
all of this is made up and they were
prints but like nice canvas prints of
classic painting starry night you know
picasso different things and they were
they said to group one you can pick one
and that's it yeah that's your painting
but it's free that's your painting and
they said to group two you can pick one
and in six weeks you can trade it in if
you change your mind
so group one picks their painting that's
their painting group two picks a
painting six weeks most of them traded
in
almost everybody trades it in
then another six weeks later they survey
group a and group b how satisfied are
you with your painting i'm sure you can
predict the outcome group a
thrilled with their painting
they love their baby i love it that is
the microcosm of the whole message
that's the whole thing right and i don't
even have to finish it group b
they hate their [__] second thing
it's amazing it's called uh the guy who
did that study uh dan gilbert uh he i
know you know part of getting the study
uh part of the study he he came up with
this phrase the psychological immune
system i love this phrase or he
popularized the phrase the psychological
immune system and what it is is we have
it's this concept that we have our our
mind and our heart and our soul um will
has a bunch of tools in its toolkit to
make us feel good about what we have
and
it's it's and they they do these famous
studies with like people who become
quadriplegics or people who win the
lottery so a thing you think
is going to totally make your life
horrible or totally make your life great
this psychological immune system just
comes in if you accept that this is what
i am dealing with right now i'm dealing
with being super rich or i'm dealing
with losing my legs or something and
then it works its magic and it starts
saying like
starts rewiring your sense of meaning
starts making you look for the good in
the thing starts or making you look for
the bad and the thing you know it's like
it's more normalizing than just like it
just normalizes
and then the people who win the lottery
um end up not being as they're a little
happier
but they end up not being as happy as
you'd expect and the people are
quadriplegic are a little more having
struggles but not as much as you'd
expect right because the adaptability
you know the quadriplegic they might you
know suddenly
discover a part of their soul that
they're really good at talking to other
quadriplegics and you know they find a
quadriplegic community they might see
that like oh i have this new thing
that's inspiring this new mountain to
climb of how to find out how this thing
happens or you know i i
learn all the i become a gear head for
all the wheelchairs and i start getting
into like cool ancient old wheelchairs
because whatever you have if you decide
and i'm not saying you know nobody
thinks you're saying i okay good i don't
like nobody privileged
bad things are bad no i know um but but
i've read those studies too or maybe
that article that was talking about
quadriplegics that that are suddenly or
maybe the one they talked to was imbued
with meaning and meaning is hard like
they're trying to make these micro
achievements and and so that their life
was given purpose totally if that makes
sense so something
i can relate in the sense that like when
my wife left me when i was 28 you didn't
want to
want it to happen but that was like a
very meaningful time in my life because
i was like i need to i need to rebuild
like as opposed to just kind of coasting
yeah which i again it's something you
never would have wanted in both of those
cases obviously one of those is very
extreme but like having something to do
and small noticeable achievements can
really enrich your life amen can i how
much are you are you a wendell berry
person do you know about wendell berry
the little caramel candies the the the
kentucky farmer philosopher poet tell me
everything oh he's great i know okay
wendelberry is um he's this uh
like uh poet of localism he's a poet of
like loving the place you are and he has
this amazing and he's a far localism
localism
like if i'm in tune with what i'm doing
right now i'm being localist that would
be like a very micro localist like what
you are right here on this couch but you
can even apply localism to that he's
more kind of on the town level i
understand like if you were like i love
la or i love this neighborhood and i'm
different i'm getting into this
neighborhood if the plane is on the
ground it'll be like good on you okay
great and um and you know i got really
into localism because of him because uh
you know you're looking for answers in
politics and there's not many localist
political causes it's all people
fighting about federal stuff um and he
has this amazing story that i just feel
brings it all together that explains how
this all works and he goes it's called
the the bucket and he goes my grandpa's
bucket it's like old kentucky farmer
poets okay i don't never seen this man
but i think i'm picturing him
and he goes you know there's a bucket
that's on a rusty nail on my grandpa's
farm
and the bucket's there and we all forgot
about the bucket and the buckets the
major fact about the bucket is it's a
receptacle and it's nailed to this post
okay that's all that matters it's just
there
and over time
uh leaves fall into the bucket and dirt
falls into the bucket and you know a
bird comes into the bucket and leaves
some feathers and bugs come into the
bucket
and um and just like all of them mix in
with each other and all these things
come and then you look at the bucket 10
years later and it's beautiful soil
and um and he goes what caused that
beautiful soil to happen it was just the
stability of the bucket and the bucket
being a receptacle and then the world
happened to the bucket and then an
amazing thing happened and everything
comes out of that soil and then he says
similarly and he talks about it on the
cultural level but i think you can talk
about it on any level he goes if you
have a stable group of people that are
in community together the equivalent of
the leaves and the feathers
um is like
someone comes up with a song one day and
they all like hum the song and they all
think it's funny and they remember that
song three years later or someone comes
up with an inside joke or someone has a
problem and someone else has a really
great insight and they try the insight
and it works and it becomes a rule of
thumb and over time that group of
friends or the way they talk to each
other nicknames or something like that
and over time you wake up 10 years later
and that group of that community that
group of friends
is rich soil
it's like it's like the most lovely
thing and you don't even know how to
describe it but what was this the fact
the two factors that made that all
happen like i could get into the
mechanical engineering of all those
things and the importance of inside
jokes and studies about that but the two
major factors at the core
are they were stable with each other
they were committed to each other yeah
yeah and they were willing to be
receptacles of
just like things that they could receive
they were receiving the flow of life the
flow of life the river and so i think
this might merge what you like talking
about and what i like talking about
which is
there's the flow of the world and all
these things happening but then if you
are willing to let the strands of time
go a little longer which is all the
commitment messages it's like just try
to do it a little longer you know try to
have a spirit of like i'm gonna go back
to this even though i don't want to
today
magic things happen we had a friend uh i
heard you magic things happen that's a
that's a trauma for me i want you to
know that i heard you because i because
i started to say something and then you
have to have jewish overlapping uh
conversation that's yeah this is a
mid-range i understand um no but uh we
had a friend me and my friend ern used
to call him bbd
and it was it was short for a bigger
better deal and it was a friend that if
you made a plan with him
he would be there unless he got a bigger
better deal okay and this was in like
junior high maybe high school it was
like
really really hurtful yeah it's one of
the like most simple things
is the bucket and the remaining kind of
quality but so few of us
do it you mentioned it in your speech
it's like the friends that don't abandon
you
because they meet some new you know
flavor of the week somebody that's
because you you isn't that there's
something to that it's like we know
you know make new friends but keep the
old sort of thing when a silver one's
gold you meet somebody you might become
enamored with a new person but there's a
deeper wisdom that goes like i think my
bucket guys the bucket boys with a z
were becoming rich soil even if there's
like a a new drifter in town that smokes
cools and leans on lampposts you know
like a cool guy yeah you know the old
me
you know i'm also half catholic so i'm
used to like moral moral righteousness
or something the old me would have said
even though that other friend is better
you must do the morally right thing
which is go back to the old friends
because that's the just and right thing
to do but what i've discovered in this
book is the deeper insight the deeper
truth is not that like you must be a
good person and go back to the old
friends the deeper truth is by going
back to the old friends it will be a
better deal for you the bigger better
deal for bbd
was you guys isn't that crazy yes he
didn't know that and part of my message
of like this whole message in this book
in the speech was like i just want to
let everyone know this isn't uh infinite
browsing mode and all these exciting
things and keeping your options open
is good but we have to be you know we
have to be good and and it's very
important to be loyal and committed it's
actually
that all leads to unhappiness
isn't that weird and this is the joy in
the long run right it's like when
morality is actually you i feel like
that's a big part of becoming an adult
is realizing that a lot of those rules
were for your own inner state not even
your social standing but how you feel
when you like we've talked about it
before but it bears repeating is it i
heard a monk on youtube talking about a
great way to fall asleep at night is
called uh swimming in a sea of merit so
you remember all the good things you did
during the day and good things you did
for yourself like i went on that walk or
good things you did for your friend i
bought lunch or whatever it might be or
maybe i was just kind to somebody often
like because i've been doing it for a
while sometimes it's just like i i
texted that person like hey i saw that
thing you made it was really great so
these things add up and it helps you
fall asleep so it's literally true
though like how do you sleep at night
like people that are [__] but it
turns out like if you do good things
during the day it'll help you fall
asleep or if you commit to your friends
these are rewards in and of themselves
which is how we started this
conversation like can you do something
not to sell books but for its own sake
because that's the richness that you
enjoy
in here that no one can see and really
no one can take from yeah right yet
you'll know way more i don't know all
these different
wisdom traditions yeah all of these
traditions but i'm not here i'm not
there yet in my life of fully seeing it
but i just have this this hint that like
goodness and truth and beauty eventually
merge
and are not like separate concepts and
like eventually
you see that the good thing to do and
the thing that leads to joy and the
thing that you find beautiful and the
thing that senses to be true and just
probably are all the same thing i don't
know yet for sure yeah i've got a hint
in my heart that's a little out of my
depth but i have heard
rupert spyra alert but rupert spyro
talks about how true it's actually on a
post-it do you see that posted on my
uh katie it says beauty
love i can see it it's the third one
from the left
understanding which is
you want to just hand me the post-it
please
he he makes the argument that they are
the same yeah that you're seeing the
this is this post-it is not going to
convince anybody but i do want to see
what it says thank you katie
uh understanding
is thinking it's like it's it's sensing
the one thing through thinking love is
sensing the one thing with feeling
and beauty is sensing this one thing the
only thing that's happening by the way
uh with perceiving
so it's like you're either perceiving
beauty
feeling love or thinking understanding
but all three of those things are really
just getting in tune with the only thing
that's going on here which is ultimately
you could say just one thing and when we
say it's love by the way it doesn't mean
like ooey gooey warm feelings it means
it's this undulating
yes yeah it's almost mad maddening yes
of expanding contracting
fractaling that has led to this absurd
conversation that we're having right
is that wild but that that i i think
there's something
to like sometimes i think about reality
is like it's a wave like there's this
tidal wave and we're right on the edge
of it like you couldn't be more on the
on the knife's edge if you try this is
the most novel moment now this is the
most it's like we're right there it's
more like racing in a car like than it
is just kind of like i'm sitting on a
couch it's like this is this is the
newest thing that's ever happened yeah
when you can get in in touch with that
it's it's super exciting they to that
too right
i love that i love that tell me tell me
what you've learned about people that
have have committed i'm one of them by
the way yeah i'll give you an example
like i i started in improv but then when
i became part of the stand-up so it
wasn't the first thing to your point
that you made earlier i still love
improv yeah and i still do improv but it
wasn't improv theater that like really
grabbed me when i found the more
uh lone wolf more autonomous i liked
being able to work on it by myself
because then the project was as
dedicated as i was where as opposed to
being on an improv team we were only as
dedicated as we were as a group so i
wanted to go like faster yeah um so by
being alone have you heard that
expression if you want to go far go
together if you want to go fast go alone
yeah i wanted to go fast
so it was like i'll get the improv later
when we shoot sketches we'll improvise
but i gotta go fast right now
um and i'm blanking on what what my
point oh
but the the richness the soil the bucket
of committing to stand up was was really
really meaningful and and then later
committing to uh valerie has been really
really meaningful tell me about some of
the people can i ask a question before i
go into that you know one of the so the
word i use for like these committers is
long-haul heroes yeah and the reason i
use long-haul heroes is because you know
when we usually think about heroism we
think about slaying the dragon in one
big brave moment right and i say the
people i that captured my admiration
were not the big barriers moment people
like i've never been into like this
person you know had three guns drawn on
him and kicked them all down and saved
the day which is all we want to see
which is what all the movies are about
and um and i was always into like the
stories that were like for 32 years you
know
someone has been doing the same thing
every week and give you and the new one
bruce eric kaplan my favorite new yorker
cartoonist submitted i think it was for
10 years he mailed the new yorker 10
cartoons every week for
almost a decade
and just got nose nose nose nose nose
nose nose and i think you're going to
like this if that were a movie if we
made a movie of bruce eric kaplan that
would be a 30-second montage
all we want is him opening the letter
and we montage i i didn't put it in the
book but i had this thought it's like
the montage is
the movie is the is the whole thing
though
all we want is winning we just want the
winner's circle you don't want the
the failing that's sort of what crashing
was about it was it was a
slowing down of the montage it was we
got to do three seasons of like no and
even that it's super sped up it's super
sped up but it was slower than usually
they're already famous comedians or or
successful or good comedians when we
start but we wanted to be like what if
he stinks
what if he's grinding oh man what was
your question though yeah so my my um
one of the long haul heroes that really
affected like the one of the earliest
seeds of this idea for me is like my
obsession with david letterman
because
i used to watch it every night
um i i wasn't
too young to have watched the original
nbc show but i watched the light show on
cbs then i watched it every night and
there was no and then i watched it all
the way to 2015 when he had his big
grand like final show and it was funny
watching the clip show and everyone like
talking about these great moments like
oh the time that he you know went uh you
know put velcro on and jumped on the
wall or the time the first time he
dropped the thing off the the roof
and i was just like these moments
don't capture david letterman at all you
know it's like and you're watching them
and they're just so small compared to
yes my experience as a person david
letterman
experience and i'm like that is not you
can't capture it with like oh that big
epic thing you know even like his great
things where he came on after 9 11 and
said a beautiful thing the thing about
david letterman was
the the corpus not the opus it was that
every night he he brought his lens to
the world and over time that lens if
you're a loyal viewer burrows into your
heart and now my whole way of being has
like it's like one percent david
letterman now that's right and he's in
your home he shows up in your home like
through on your tv yeah but he comes to
where you're sitting that's what i when
people want to start podcasts i always
tell them the one thing
it's a relationship and you have to be
consistent totally you tell them we're
going to be on every wednesday you have
to be on every wednesday totally
because that's david letterman
david letterman was like
i i really think our animal minds are
this simple he was your friend totally
you know yes he showed up what is a
friend someone who shows up when they
say
he was loyal to uh you know it sounds
totally completely
well it's like which who are we talking
about bruce wayne or batman it's like
when you become a symbol when you become
something bigger than the man yeah so
when you become a tv she that's what the
band is and the lights and the
broadcasts it turns him into something
bigger than just david david what i'm
saying is lowercase d david doesn't give
a [__] about you yeah but uppercase d
came into your home in your heart every
day and
well doing that by coming into
everyone's home he's just chipping away
at the cult just pushing the culture
just like one little inch by one way he
asks a question or one way he finds
something funny and then you wake up on
the other end in 2015 and not in 1979 or
whenever he was at the comedy store or
something um and the culture is
different because he
turned away at that and i don't think
one perfect movie that he did would have
done that i completely agree and now the
culture seems to have shift somebody was
just we had work day at our preschool
today so we were like shoveling the sand
and at leela school we were having this
conversation and somebody started
explaining what some tick talker had
done
i'm not even putting it down i'm just
saying like when you when you don't know
who a tick talker is like you don't know
kid licorice and someone starts talking
about kid
licorice they were literally like kid
licorice puts salt on his hand and he he
throws it to a donkey and you're just
like this is nothing
i'm not saying maybe if you invest in
kid licorice isn't a fake name but if
you stay with that person for 10 years
maybe that is a meaningful relationship
but we've gotten
it's almost like the whole grocery store
is turned into just the samples we just
have these little samples totally
instead of that
almost marital
can relationship you had with david
letterman and you're gonna forget kid
licorice you're gonna forget
i'm gonna be in the retirement home
being like you know will it float i i
heard dane cook say two things come to
mind dan cook i was the first person i
heard say like i have to keep feeding my
fans uh content i have to keep giving
them more but that's a person that
understood that it was a relationship
and what they wanted was this
content is such a shallow word but he
means more comedy more stuff for them to
eat the other thing before we get to
your question and we will
i remember conan said this to me name
droppy but he he was like
there's all this noise you're gonna love
this this could have gone in your book
and he's like i feel like my whole
career i've just been standing in the in
all of this noise people have tubas
people have synthesizers people have
guitars people are dropping their
guitars and grabbing tubes people are
dropping their tubas and grabbing
guitars and it's just a cacophony of
chaos and he's like i stood in the
center i stayed where i was i just kept
hitting the triangle ding ding ding ding
he's like that's what you should do he's
like just keep doing what you do
and eventually the powers that be the
people that book the shows or make the
deals or whatever they they're like look
i've been putting my ear to
show business
what is that it starts to emerge from
the wall of chaos you go like what is
that ding ding ding that i've been
hearing for 10 years and you hire the
ding ding ding
jim gaffigan
used to be one of the
he wasn't like
ridiculed but it's sort of a famous
thing that when jim gaffigan started
let's put it this way i bet he was funny
but no one liked him and that's
important
like when i got to new york
i still met people that thought it was
crazy that he was starting to blow up
they were like jim gaffigan that's a guy
that was ding ding ding but if you're
starting and you're not like ripe yet
and you're just going that's silly
that's insane or whatever just sort of
looks dumb but you ding ding ding long
enough that's like let the [__] bread
rise in the oven but too many people are
going like it's still dough change it
yeah
yeah it's i gotta get a different
instrument i gotta do that exactly
people are into this instrument now and
that's the desperation that we were
talking about no one wants someone
selling a book and no one wants going
like do you want me to be a musician
should i do parody videos like just do
what's written inside of your bones and
you can see so many examples of that i
like this example because it's like
famous people and we love them and so
yeah but wow it's you know the math
teacher that calmly teaches math every
week we just had the 50th anniversary of
the crossing guard in my neighborhood
they named the crosswalk after the
crossing guard
and you know from you know the people
that chip away at a cause you know like
you can see the politicians
the types of politicians that young
people are drawn to in the deepest way
are not the glitzy glammy ones they're
the ones that have been hammering away
at something for 30 years yeah bernie
comes yes yeah he's he's a great example
of that it's what a triangle hitter you
know just in backbencher in vermont
hitting the triangle and that is the
most triangle hitter good on you you
coined a new phrase
he's a real triangle hitter and then you
gotta have faith you know if it's coming
from a true place you got to just have
faith that either your time will come
well it'll hit the zeitgeist or if it
never hits the zeitgeist that was your
truth and that was a beautiful thing to
do
we i just did a show
i won't mention the musician in case
this is disparaging in any way but like
i was talking to kenneth uh one of the
guys from milk carton kids he was at my
show last night we were hanging out and
our musical guest was amazing like
clearly a genius and but we were like
kenneth was like you know 15 years ago
this guy might have been like i'll be
headlining the bowl like that's the goal
but like he stayed on the path and now
maybe he scores movies or he produces
records but he's still being a genius
still doing his thing but it wasn't
necessarily
it's not an all or nothing zero sum sort
of like either your dream comes true or
doesn't for some reason the triangle
hitting doesn't mean you get plucked and
get to be conan o'brien totally means
sometimes they dedicate a crosswalk to
you or sometimes you taught some kids
math and made their lives better it
doesn't necessarily mean fame and
fortune you know even just you know i i
sometimes i talk about these grand
examples of commitment
even just every parent
you know everyone who's married everyone
who's a good friend
it's like um
that's the triangle hitting of you know
going over to linda's house and having
brunch every month and
you know and then seeing linda through
her marriage and her divorce and her you
know her first kid and then the hard
career thing and then the great career
thing yeah and then you know the
conversation you have 20 years later is
the simplest conversation but it's so
deeper than anything else and it feels
so much better than anything else
and that's much better than the friend
that was exactly like you and said the
most charismatic thing and right now the
moments
also yeah and you went viral yes who
cares this is really interesting stuff
but how do you make it
how do you make anybody care about this
you know i think you know i got a few i
care i'm glad you and a lot of people
bought the book the reason i i actually
the way i came into this journey you
know part of it we've talked a lot about
part of it which is i just had this i'm
a commitment super fan i love long haul
heroes i collect all these stories oh
diana nyada's tried five times to swim
from cuba to key west i love it like
i'll eat it up so that's that's my um
that's my lincoln's one of those big
failure guys too oh my god abraham yes
no lost every election but one and then
yes yes
so i was into that but what was the
movie lincoln already president yes
already and some grand moment yeah
him as a
yes
where we open in a prison in asia the
lincoln's a good example of this
other half
is um
i actually think that
commitment is the solution to many of
the questions is the answer to many of
the questions that people are asking so
the other half of this is
i wanted to like the other river that
came together for the speech in this
book was so many people my age um are
hopeless you know about public life you
know maybe they've escaped to some like
private private adventure enjoy but like
about public life life in community life
and politics life in society life and
institutions you know they feel isolated
they feel like the institutions are
crumbling and rested they feel like
we've tried different hopes so this
candidate will solve everything or this
technology will solve everything and
then those hopes are dash and everyone's
looking for where to go
and when it comes to impact like healing
the the wounds of our of our time
um solving the great problems of our
time you know fighting the important
civic battles of our time
they're all going to be 30-year
struggles
you know the heroes should not be when
we're looking you know i love this one
guy told me once and i love this this
idea my heroes aren't just the civil
rights movement people in the 1960s my
heroes are the civil rights movement
people of the 1920s you know like
because they started rolling they
started rolling a ball yeah and um and
it was much harder for them you know it
was hard for the people of the 60s but
it was really hard for the people in the
20s
you know that and but there's no
three-act structure to that yeah they
don't get their win they don't get their
story yeah unless they come back as a
member of the 60s generation goes oh
that was pretty cool even though they
failed i should try to
it's not sexy it's not flashy yeah but
the thing is this isn't like you know we
have to walk through the desert for 200
years amazing things happen in 30 to 40
years like
the abolition movement you know i we
don't talk enough about it it's the most
amazing movement in american history it
is the greatest moment of america we had
the most horrific thing happen the
original sin of america and a group of
less than one percent of this country
got together
upended in the entire country to get rid
of this stain to the best that they
could
and
you know there are early abolitionists
there's people in the 1700s there's
people in the 1600s there's people in
the early 1800s but it really doesn't
get going until like the 1820s 1830s
like the first newspaper the liberator
the big abolitionist newspaper 32 years
before emancipation proclamation
and these people got together they were
all friends
they they did the 30 years of marching
they did the point where was not even
allowed to talk about it to the point
where they were the crazy ones to the
point where it was a debate to the point
where they had a party to the point
where we had a civil war over them and
we say it was over slavery no it was
over the abolitionists yeah cut to those
guys going and this is our fault right
but i mean it was a big deal it was it
was a it was a war but it was good it
was a good one yeah and uh yeah they're
like whoa
they all i love i put this in the book
this is my favorite image is
when the emancipation proclamation was
set to be passed they got word from the
lincoln administration like hey we're
going to sign it tonight if you guys
want to know hey this is all thanks to
you so i just want to let you know we're
gonna find it tonight they all gathered
in boston at um two different buildings
and they had a party
and all of the people from the 30 years
got together and had a party
and and then someone came running in
very dramatic moment and they said
he signed it the emancipation
proclamation and like they have all
these grant like bonnets were thrown in
the air old enemies hugged and like they
had a moment and um where it happened
and they felt that celebration and i
just want to tell people for all these
problems we face today like the idea
that we transition off of fossil fuels
the idea that we'd have a just economy
the idea that our democracy would be
healthy again not a total mess yeah um
we don't know if 35 years from now if we
all got a little committed to our corner
to our instrument
um
we might have a similar party yeah
and uh and throw bonnets in there
fashion is circular so but i love that
and we're not hearing enough of that i i
think well you tell me it seems like a
symptom of this browsing culture that we
feel so daunted by
any
immovable object you meet all these
people and they say you know i used to
be hopeful like you pete but then i
tried one thing and it didn't work
yeah now i'm not naive anymore i know
the score right but it's like no if you
really know the score
you know
evan wolfson a young lawyer wrote as his
3l paper at law school
the constitutional right to gay marriage
and the comments he got back
were this is a crazy science fiction
law review article you should have
worked on some serious issue not some
like theoretical idea of like you know
what if what if we put this in space or
whatever you know
mars law it was like as normal as
writing an article on mars law right and
then he spends ten years like shopping
his article around and then he gets the
point where he has to convince the i
interviewed him for the book he had to
convince the gay rights movement to even
agree with him he had to convince his
own movement to agree with his cause
within the movement that's always the
first 10 years can you convince yourself
um and then then he has the state by
state fights then it's 2004 and
everyone's passing these state
constitutional amendments against the
stuff and he's in the total doldrums but
he remembers history and he says there's
always dark times and then he keeps
marching and then in the supreme court
decision obergefell that that legalize
gay marriage they cite stuff from his
law review article they like same
similar languages and i go so who's the
naive one were you then are you is evan
wolfson the naive one or is the person
who said you know we had a campaign and
it didn't work and then we had another
campaign it didn't work and that's i
believe the world will never change
so that is my case for that is like why
we got to do this
for the stuff out there but
we talked in the opening of this the
stuff in there he had a whole lot of fun
the whole time while he was doing it and
he feels a lot of purpose he has a lot
of friends and the whole world has
opened up to him in depth so wow while
he was doing it because following his
bliss sort of thing following something
that he believed in gave his life
meaning so it's both it was the moral
thing to do and it benefited yeah that's
so cool why do we i mean we love people
that are like
i think it's our protectors that want to
be like get real
grow up those are the parts you never
want to play in the movie yeah i
remember i i auditioned for the part in
king richard where i was like the slick
agent that was like look rich like your
kids aren't
like both of them aren't gonna be tennis
superstars like it's not like a fun role
no one wants to play the person that
reads the gay rights thing and goes like
this is science fiction people people
like what a heel
but like so many people the majority of
people are
that way and it's really wonderful to
hear that story
like don't you find that like it's
almost cool to be like
that's never gonna happen like it or
it's safe at least yeah and i think
we're all trying to protect ourselves
and we're we're we don't want to look
dumb it's fear of vulnerability it's the
cult of smart you know right now that's
this great phrase we got we got call to
smart the only thing that should be
smart are our phones you know you know
um and
it's like you don't want to be
no no one wants to be caught like taking
a risk
being had and the thing is like that
fear is actually what is stopping us
from
right from have finding the stuff we're
all looking for i say this all the time
but it was i got it from uh game makers
toolkit which is a great youtube channel
that i really like they talk about in
game development i forget which game
company it was but they had a slogan on
the wall that said fail faster find the
fun and i just love the
you get it immediately because we're
completely in sync
not don't fail which is the people that
are like you're never gonna do that
that's stupid fail faster like let's get
on with the failing let's let's get the
people telling me this is [__] let's
get my own cause not even agreeing with
me get to it because that's like a sign
you're on the right path that's what i
tell people that's that's the lineage of
stand up and we do have to get to your
question is i'm like if it sucks that's
how you know you're doing it right
that's that's the line we put in
crashing i was like and then you almost
have to mythologize that if you're
starting stand up go and if you're
eating [__] even our phrases are fun we
have to try and make it fun because it's
so hard you're eating [__] you're eating
a [__] sandwich you're bombing you're
sweating it sucks
that
like
solidifies you into a community that
have all done that totally
like dave chappelle might be an uh an
example of someone who didn't really
bomb there's always like the the paul
bunyans of the world but i promise you
everyone else knows richard pryor
certainly ate [__] especially the time
that he was in uh whoever name anybody
they they know what it's like to bump so
you i've i've seen bill burr have soft
sets before he was bill burr because the
crowd sucked and maybe he's tired like
everyone was just kind of finding it
bill was working out some new stuff i
promise so you start going like talk
about images and symbols you go like i'm
batman and sometimes the joker gets a
few hits in well just just hearing about
this isn't that just so isn't it so
romantic it's the definition of romance
yeah the capital r it's absolute romance
and you start to go like
it it's like getting your hits or
something i think about male initiation
rights where where where there's uh
starving the kid or you know not not to
death but like three days in the
wilderness
like you i hear those stories obviously
i go that's so absurd and barbaric or
grotesque or strange or unfamiliar but
i'm like starting stand-up comedy
really uh
welds you into a community because
you're like i now that i've put in all
of that it's why i won't stop first of
all i really love it but second of all
if i don't feel like doing a spot i'm
like do it for that kid who used to
drive between dakotas and eat [__] at
technical colleges for shows while they
were serving lunch go tell him that you
don't want to drop by the comedy story
like like [__] you you you put in too
much pain it's what they call in poker
your pot committed yeah you put so much
money in the middle you have to keep
playing yeah and part of my message is
you know that's not a thing to that's
not a bug that's a feature
that's not a bug
that's a feature but that's it that's
what we mean when we're talking about a
community or a craft you know do you
know what this gets at that's so fun
been so funny in this process so you
know i'm not like a self-help right i
made fun of rise and grind early in this
conversation like
my book you know i like philosophy and
sociology and all this stuff i like
reading all these like peep social
theory people and like
all the stuff and nothing against
different worlds but it's just not my
world of like life hacker tim ferriss or
something yeah yeah sure yeah and um but
my book got um
categorized in the dewey decimal system
as a self-help book
shout out to the dewey decimal conan the
librarian it's like self-help and that's
where it is in the bookstores that's
where it's in the library yeah and so i
go on some of these podcasts sometimes
that are like super rise and ground
self-help podcasts and i always
disappoint them because they um
they think that the commitment when i'm
talking about commitment i'm tired this
is connected to the stand-up thing they
think when i'm talking about commitment
i'm talking about like committing to a
gym routine or committing to a diet and
it's like all self-commitments it's like
you know you you have a moment where you
want to be soft but pete's book is about
how you need to be hard and do the long
thing right but
i say i'm so sorry this that is not what
i'm saying at all um all of the
commitments that i reference and all of
the categorizations i put in the book
and in the speech by commitment or about
to commitment to something outside of
yourself so the more important thing in
the stand-up story is not necessarily
just your commitment to your own
stand-up career it's to the practice yes
of stand-up it's too
that when you decided to commit to it it
wasn't just like you're now honing a
skill and that skill will be in your
tool kit that will make you more
powerful right
a video game i'll get experience points
and i'll get stronger and stronger and i
can fight bigger dragons oh it's it's
like you join a thing
that connects
lenny bruce
to the jesters in the medieval times yes
to your to the front
to like oh you know to a comment that's
like oh jerry seinfeld was part of the
older class and i'm now part of this
generation and now oh he was i was a
little older than him yeah and whoever
the the door person at different comedy
clubs and things like that and you
become part of a culture of a lineage of
a lineage and he started moving
something called comedy the the i don't
do it as much as i used to but they used
to feel like you sacrificed this is
absurd i'm i'm channeling 25 year old no
i wasn't 25. like 32 year old pete would
have been like
you you can't have a normal relationship
you sacrifice that on the altar of
comedy that's what i really believed and
you could say that at an open mic and uh
five six crusty weird men and women
would nod along with you and be like
that that we we get up our own butt a
lot but really it's all in the service
of this
mythology that that makes it so fun in
the same way that sports fandom can be
really fun or following history or
whatever or a tv show we were making our
own mythology and being like comedy
which doesn't exist yeah it does but
it's not really real
you know what i mean like show it to me
it's it's a it's like a mist over a
large group of happenings and but we we
treated it almost like a deity totally
totally yeah this is there's this great
philosopher alastair mcintyre who says
um everything is about practices you
know like the practice of comedy the
practice of chess the practice of
medicine or pharmacies or something and
he says um
you know most of morality this is the
funny thing like most of our stories of
what it means to be a good person what
it means to be a heroic person
only exists within the context
of a community of people watching you
and finding meaning in that goodness and
in that heroism so the idea of that was
heroic for tony hawk to do a 900
has no meaning at all if tony hawk is
alone
doing a 900. there won't even be a
skatepark because there's no practice so
like he finds something that's shaped
like a ramp and he does the 900 it
doesn't or the mctwist or something it
means nothing but because
a culture has built built up that is
stable a bucket that is a receptive
bucket has built up that has
all these elements to it like i call
them constellations of meaning like the
boards and the different board companies
and the different shoes and the
different shoes companies and the
different ways you
uh take turns going into the bowl with
the board and the different people and
the different legendary people means
that when tony hawk did the 900 at the x
games in the 90s
the sublimity that was felt the portal
to god
was deeper was more there because of an
agreed work yes and so when that went
this is the funny story i'm sad i
learned about this after the book tony
hawk's dad okay this is my favorite
favorite fact about this tony hawk's dad
helped
create the first tournaments of vertical
skateboarding and he did all the busy
work of it because he thought oh my
son's really into this it's this kind of
like informal subculture and i'll try to
bring it up to the next level by hosting
tournaments and getting sponsors and
getting all the different skateboard
companies to sponsor it thus
bringing the practice to the next level
and so
without the tony hawk's dads of the
world
creating the practices
every um there is no heroism or
sublimity in anything that anyone does
so
every the person that hosts the open mic
and sets up the microphone and does the
av yes and um the critic that writes a
comedy column the youtube reaction video
that says like this is what you know
this is how pete holmes has changed and
how he compares to this right makes
is all part of the constellation of
meaning that makes when you land a good
joke that's that's what i mean by the
myth
and when you zoom in on the myths it's
all it's a constellation is better
because these things that are tied
together and we're all co-conspiring to
make
culture yes exactly because because
not because it's not there's nothing
else to do or would just be waiting
around to die although i suppose that's
part of it it's because it feels so
[__] good like when i get really
i can get really flared up about
different things like we got really
excited about espresso
so so dumb but we bought a nice machine
and we got the beans and the grinders
but like it mattered because i did all
this research to make it better and now
we're drinking val and i are getting
high on espresso drinking it being like
you see how it's rounder you know what i
mean like but like i love and then i
find out they have barista competitions
and they have to make a flat white in
like 30 seconds
we'll go drive out 45 minutes and go get
this thing and then we'll take the
different flat right because that's what
life seems to be yeah and that's just
another first of all it's an excuse to
be together which i think is one totally
meanings of life it's an excuse to be
together as a way of loving people tony
hawk is really good at standing on a
board with four wheels on it
like
before that culture before those
constellations of meaning were
established
kind of who cares totally even i i know
that sounds absurd because what he does
is so impressive but maybe he's a bad
example because he is so spectacular but
like but maybe it's like show that to my
mom though if my mom's in a rush
yeah
she's on her way to stop and shout out
to you explain to your mother later
watch the tony hawk documentary and see
that and if i get her stand on the board
yeah and see it yeah look at how hard
you got into skateboarding and she
suddenly oh skateboarding is now in the
family so now i got to care about tony
hawk more that's exactly right and right
all the networks like your relationship
with your mom your relationship with
tony hawk you know and the dad
seeing my son is really into this
that that fandom and that enthusiasm is
another form of love he was loving his
son yeah and then the fans are loving
i i'm not saying it's real love that you
can like take to the bank and and like
like the way that you love love your
daughter is his son or daughter son yeah
love your son that's a different thing
but it is a culture love it's a it's a
like it's another beat of that yeah some
it's some form of it yeah and you know
the the stakes of this the the reason
why i think this is like a message now
is like if this if your if our life gets
so broken up into tiny little browsing
swiping pieces that it's like here's the
900 here's the mctwist here's you
drinking an espresso here's another
drink here's a culture here's like
here's something from oaxaca here's
something from japan you know it's like
you will
you know the algorithms will raise the
things that in five seconds will be the
most interesting things in five seconds
context-less to the top
but that that is like i feel like we're
we're getting off at level 5 out of 10
when the 10 out of 10s come from
come from uh you know and we could live
a 5 out of 10 for the rest of humanity
or something but the 10 out of 10's come
from you getting really into espresso
and then reading the books on espresso
or following the band and they never
play that song live oh and now you two
just played sunday bloody sunday and
you're like oh my god like that
i i've said this a million times but i'm
gonna say it to you because i'd like to
see what so richard rohr who's a great
teacher of mine
oh you do yeah catholic here yes oh man
i love that i okay so he says his one of
the definitions of evil
he says is anything that lies about the
fundamental nature of reality
he doesn't say this i took that to be
like
look i i use instagram i post on
instagram all that sort of stuff so i'm
not i'm not saying it's evil
full stop i'm saying when when
reality is purported to be
these five-second images that is
potentially
evil it's lying it's lying to say
reality is you
being happy at the beach long enough to
do a story and then miserable the rest
of the like totally we don't care if
you're not really on a private plane as
long as you look like you're on a
private plane and gone
you know we sound like two old farts but
like the jack kerouac the people living
in the flow living in the cast having an
authentic experience i don't care that i
sound like an old fogey like [__]
everybody like if you can actually take
the amtrak from boston to new york and
actually with the same fascination that
you would have if you were in virtual
reality or a dream but you become lucid
in your dream and really
hear the tracks
see the out the window
own the idea that there's other
consciousnesses in other vessels seated
next to you with the same intensity that
you that you did when you couldn't see
people after the pandemic now you're
back together but really owning that and
feeling it in your gut that is better
than every trending video
shot into your [__] by a million by a
million by a million you and i having
this conversation and dropping anchor
into it is bad i just met you it's
better than the video i saw of
slow-motion toffee getting pulled by a
machine in fact
[__] you slow-motion toffee i mean it
you're lying to me
you're telling me that you're life
you're not life you're nothing that's
totally nothing
i've often thought we need like i i
actually think i'm gonna lay out a
prediction here on you made it weird all
out of prediction here it is so bring it
back cut it put it on twitter when it
comes to past 20 years right pete
predicted it no you oh yeah
i was like what do you mean
i thought you were peter you're also
people i also picked good for you who
has the time can we i'm glad you didn't
bring it up pete davidson my name's pete
davis dude you're on google how would
you feel what would you feel if when you
were growing up when you're about to
enter your life
someone on snl was named pete holmson
and you were about to trying to be a
public figure in life and then suddenly
you're like oh it's okay you know a lot
of snl people flame out and then he
becomes famous and famous
yes and now dude spelling out pete davis
which i did i in doing my research of
you people david auto correct google
google says like you don't matter
something else matters yes
you and you know what that is that's
evil that's you're lying that pete davis
doesn't exist that's a lie that's yeah
i'm talking i'm just i'm accepting my
faith like i will be under the shadow
yeah keep going but um
i think there will actually be something
resembling
a religious uh a like religious ask
movement against the phones and against
the feeds like i think
like i think there will be something
that
becomes like how the mormons don't drink
yes or the amish or the amish and it'll
be like
i'm a blank i don't i don't i don't
participate in social i agree have you
seen the noah bomb back movie
is it called while we're young
it is ben stiller adam driver anyway he
meets these two brooklyn hipsters that
are like we watch movies on vhs yeah
like we we rent them we watch them we
sit and we watch them but commitment was
sort of imposed on us in a way that it's
no longer imposed to us i see my
daughter unfortunately you know it's
it's okay it's okay like things are
gonna go goofy and we'll figure them out
but like she was watching bambi this
morning
and i was really touched to see
how like invested she was in bambi and i
i haven't seen bammy in a long time it's
a it's a beautiful movie but it's boring
it's like the first five minutes or an
owl flying in a tree
and then he falls asleep and then it
pans up and there's a squirrel waking up
like that is not the definition of
entertainment anymore like some animals
are nocturnal like that's a snooze but
here's leela invested but after about
15-20 minutes i really noted it because
bambi's mom hadn't died yet because i
was getting ready to be like
uh you know you help her through that
let her see it but because i feel like
she's ready but like because she's
talking about death and stuff anyway she
swapped over to 101 dalmatians so it was
like it's already
happening
that like it's not baked in we didn't
rent the puffy white vhs tape and open
it
she knows how to leave the app and go
and pick another movie and i was like
what happened to bambi and she's like
this is a better one and i was like oh
god okay so it begins the infinite
browsing reads i know but she needs to
have this buddy i remember this might
just be super nostalgic but it's like
the nickelodeon movies used to be in an
orange case yes and then you'd open the
orange case and and what we don't get is
the orange case was part of the movie it
was not ancillary to the movie the whole
experience is the experience okay so
jerry seinfeld in sign language is the
only time i found it i've never seen him
do it live i mean he says going to the
movies is the movie yes yes yes yes this
is like that's wisdom that's part of the
message you think you like stand-up
comedy like i said i had a great show
last night and then my set was good but
hanging out with the comedians human
heat eye contact the the imperceivable
or like sub-perceptual things like the
smell of other people's deodorants or
whatever like that that all together the
constellation of meaning are
the feeling of being alive it's not just
jump like if i could teleport which is
what vr would be that's why i'm like
well you can do a show in vr right the
logic is being baked into all the new
technologies because when they're
thinking like what would be a cool
technology they're thinking let's keep
going down the path yes as far as we can
and i'm like well we gotta get off the
path and i can just drop in and i'm
already doing the show hello and like
that's not that's not comedy comedy is
me in the car
listening to my own [__]
remembering how to be funny or or or
feeling good feeling nervous checking in
with my body that's doing stand-up
comedy it's not just
opening a door like quantum leap and i'm
just there yeah it's like and we get it
for things that we still have still
survived the great like fracturing of
everything yes like friendship is so
clearly not someone who optimizes advice
and like says aha to you it's it's like
a hundred times more than that yes you
know and we know that but my argument is
basically that's for everything so like
like you know marriage is not just like
you do logistics together in a house
right you know it's everything right and
i'm just like but the same is true for
like picking something up at the
convenience store or something but
the thing is
is running out of milk and going to the
store so the store that's what life is
and as soon as you figure that out and
start enjoying and being embodied as you
go to the store to get the milk instead
of being like gotta get the [__] milk
so we can have this dinner
life is happening right now [__] and
it's what's fun is you can just layer on
more and more meaning you can be like
you can read about milk you can read
about the path to milk you read about
the urban design or oh wow i live in a
walkable city i can walk to the milk oh
there's this whole movement of walkable
cities or get curious about your hatred
of that experience oh yeah like even if
you're into the south yeah yeah like oh
why do i hate it and then like literally
gosh there's a book on this i should go
to the library and see if there's a book
or i like cover that horrible family
dinner you had where you were staring at
the glistening milk you know what i mean
like but get cured like even if you're
if you because i don't always feel
enthusiastic i don't always feel curious
in fact i go through week-long stretches
where i am actively
not curious
okay
lean into that that's what val has
taught me she's like just be the
uncurious guy my friend james was like
pete you're one of the most curious
people i know you can't take a week and
not be curious
get curious about how uncurious you are
i love that or how lazy you are or how
not reading you are or how like watching
[__] gilmore girls for the fifth time
you are like just do what you're doing
because that's
i we say it all the time but how you
feel how you feel pete right now katie
how you feel right now is your life yes
it's that's what we're back to rocking
chair it's not looking back
and doing your own david letterman
velcro wall greatest hits it's all right
here it all led to this
it's all accessible how you feel about
your life right now is your life yes yes
it's your life amen that's it not going
like i played like one of the ones i
always go to is i did a show with dave
chabel at radio city it's nothing
show it to me it's not there
what's here is this yes
that's not that gives me nothing was it
was it any better than
just doing another show on a random day
well i could tell you why it was worse
they took my phone away all these
different things it's a whole story but
to your point yeah almost always the
answer would be no because the show
isn't that the show was yeah i what i
remember is it we smoked a joint
afterwards and i i remember chappelle
handing me the joint i thought that was
really exciting that's like an american
iconic moment it was i i don't even know
if he smokes weed but like he he lit it
and he gave it to me which i was like
but i was depressed because i didn't
have a good set
let's see this is what it all happens
buddy because sorry we were on something
else but like i i put too much meaning
on how the show should have gone yeah
and i wasn't present for like instead of
just participating in the constellation
i wish i could just there were other
people that did radio city musical
that'd be part of who else did this yeah
but i just wish i could be like an alien
like capex like like just walking around
being like oh this is what it's like
because at radio city i didn't feel
welcomed i was like wow this is a weird
dream i'm having like i feel so small oh
i'm not gonna do well i'm nervous
that's fun like like that's that's my
favorite space to be the appreciator of
all things yes i love that oh my gosh
what was your question or tell me what
else you got yeah one thing on the old
fogies thing i wanted to i wanted to say
something otherwise you know one of my
one of the things i i've played with
with like thinking about all the what's
great about writing a book this is what
people don't get you think it's like
you're creating this product and then
you ship the product it's more just like
you get to think about something for a
long time and just have a bunch of
conversations about it yeah and the
funniest thing is you end at the end of
publicizing the book wishing you could
rewrite the book again because you've
just had 100 conversations with people
about it and um but the old folky thing
i've been thinking about a lot in this
whole journey
which is you know there are these
nostalgics who are like oh the good old
days when you could ride the train or
you could do this or before the tick
tocks or before
my orange vhs tapes from nickelodeon or
something but
one of my goals is to free
the essence of commitment from the past
so that it can be in the future by which
i mean
you can start a tradition right now like
it does not have to be the old stuff it
could be some weird techno cyber
commitment yes you know it could be like
you know it doesn't have to be remember
we all used to sit at coffee shops and
talk about ideas it could be like you
are free
we're all doing something else but if
you the essence that you love from the
past is the commitment is the fact that
something grew yes i never got this
interview for the book but um i wanted
to interview the guys that designed the
washington nationals culture because you
got the red sox and the yankees and they
have sweet caroline during the seventh
inning they got the famous pinstripes
thing yeah and then you have this new
baseball team in 2005 and it's like they
have all of baseball is commitment all
of baseball is just the the bucket you
know yankee stadium is here and it has a
hundred yes 100 years of leaves in it
and it's the best soil ever um but
washington national says nothing and i
really wanted i didn't get to interview
them but i really wanted to feature them
because i want to say the message of
this book and this whole message is
what are you guys gonna start and then
they invented something they invented
the presidential head races where the
three four guys get into these giant
presidential heads and they run around
and they picked a song like they got
they picked a song for the seventh
inning
and then the first year it's like the
first yeah the first time they play it
they're like uh okay but then the second
year someone has a memory they went with
their dad the last year then the fifth
now we're on year you know 15 of it and
suddenly it's like oh that was the song
that played when we won the world series
and that was the song that played when
my dad's not around anymore but but when
i went with my dad that song played and
now the song in the seventh ending
stretch has a crude meaning and so my
message is don't go to yankee stadium
you don't have to be nostalgic for the
good old days yes you could be the
nationals and make your new thing by the
way first of all i love you and this is
great two uh so the first christmas was
that way
like the first christmas was like why
are you bringing a tree inside of crazy
that's insane ho ho ho get the [__] out
of here second christmas all right i'll
hang my socks over by the fire oh you're
doing the thing again the stick the
stick okay it's all made up it's all
made up but that doesn't mean it's not
right now you see a tree and you like
cry and weave exactly all of the meaning
in your life just to lean into how weird
it is it's all
a co-conspiracy yeah two things about
that one my friend yoni weinberg who i
love he's a great writer uh very funny
guy he opted out he only does dating in
the wild he's a single guy and he was
like these apps are making me depressed
i got off all of them and he used to
come into the room and he was like yeah
i got in an uber pool and i met this
young woman and he doesn't know her five
favorite foods they and they go on a
date and they [__] live in the moment
and he he used to go on and on about how
incredible it was not just to do it but
to reclaim to realize what you're
realizing which is like wait a minute
that's real freedom you can go to a
coffee shop you can go to a trivia night
you can host a movie night where we're
not allowed to flip we're all going to
watch this [__] movie and we're not
going to second screen so there there
are cases like yoni that are doing this
the second thing i want to say about
nostalgia
that like oh we used to be able to ride
the train
and i i i love my dad i'm not [__]
on him but my dad didn't have a cell
phone but he was on his phone
yes yes yes you know what i'm saying
like people in the 80s
that didn't have tick tock or didn't
even obviously we're still up here just
watching richard rohr says most of our
thoughts is like a dog going back to its
vomit it's repetitive
endless if you could type it out on on
tiki tape it would just be like the same
[__] over and over do they like nonsense
anxieties so there were people in the
80s taking the amtrak from boston to new
york that weren't watching instagram but
they were watching a looping video of a
dog catching a frisbee because it was
better than feeling their feelings so
there are always ways that's what makes
the phone so offensive i think is it's
to use a big word it's the manifestation
or the materialization of a problem
human beings have always had which is we
would rather look at some nonsense than
actually do what we're doing yes
and honestly to have some compassion
there often what we're doing is
uncomfortable or uncertain so like
you'll catch me looking at my phone if
i'm at in a a picnic and i don't know
anybody absolutely but before i had my
phone i might have just looked down and
and thought about a weird al video that
i really liked it's the same thing
everything is similar the hard part is
everything
is uh everything is a valley
before you get the gifts basically like
any commitment is basically like the
first thing is always worse than netflix
you know like it's like it's like going
to the community meeting going to the
neighborhood picnic the first time
will be worse
than seeing your old friends or
or
or watching an interesting thing on
online
it might be worse the second time and
the third time but then you just go down
and then the goal is you just gotta or
and that's just like meeting people you
know starting a new starting stand-up
you know bombing is much worse than not
you know thinking the jokes alone in
your in your head where they're good um
and then
and there's like also like an
information aspect to it where it's like
you enter something new and it's just
like the chaos of meaninglessness
there's no
your your psychological immune system
hasn't kicked in yet it's just like all
this new information that has no meaning
to me and no purpose to me and no
community to me but you just have to
wait it out
and you just have to stick with it and
then you cross the line where it
suddenly becomes better than netflix or
better than yes you know something
that's familiar and then it just goes
off to the stratosphere basically after
that sorry to keep mentioning crashing
but but i am proud of it and that was
sort of the point was a lot of people
want to be a famous comedian and the
whole thing was like this is what being
a famous community is handing out flyers
being scared
bombing feeling like you don't belong
and then and this is what i heard you
just saying
it's almost like the meaning of life
so much of our life is now looking back
i hang out with moshe cash or something
you look back on the horrible stories
and those actually are like the
foundation upon which you built
what it means to be a comedian totally
your badges of honor yes all your best
stories are the things you didn't want
to happen yeah no i've i've had times
where
i have
this is a totally weird feeling i've
never thought about it till just now
where i wish i had more bad things
happen in the past to have funny stories
about them
or like not or to have like oh the
feeling of the grind or something or the
and i was like oh yeah that that that
aspect of my life wasn't as hard as it
was i wish i had the horrible night or
something and so that must reveal
something about the horrible nights that
they're actually we were really gonna
age like winery yes exactly
if we had courage we would pray
or hope for
uh richard rohr does pray for one
humiliation a day
that's something that he said in his new
yorker interview and i just i i've
started doing they can be little yeah
but when you start looking for them
they're kind of everywhere if you're
sensitive like me
that that cashier gave me two pennies
but she took out the dirty pennies she
could have given me shiny pennies you
know i had like something pathetic like
that but like
if we were really at the end of our
lives we'll look back and be like i i
should have had more disasters yes
because
and again richard versus if if what
you're doing is working you'll never
change and change is sort of the juice
of life right it's like the best to to
evolve and adapt and grow
and you won't do it
unless
something that you didn't ask for sort
of that's just how human beings are yes
we don't change if it's working
that's how i feel about the the multicam
i was doing how we roll just got
canceled yeah and it like fills you with
this charge that you it you didn't want
it to happen but suddenly you're like i
got to adapt i got to evolve and you
feel more alive than you have
in a long time yeah has that been hard
it's because it's you know there's this
aspect that a lot of people bring up and
i i really respect it as a critique of
the commitment thing which is you're not
in charge of all of your commitments
that's right and sometimes they can be
ripped from you that's right that's the
risk yeah and so like you you you put
your heart into you you pour yourself
all in and you have all these all the
things i talk about you have these
senses of meaning you have these rituals
you have these rhythms you have this
community people yeah it was the most
common and that must be really hard to
have it be you know you would come down
and say like tv guards and say yes
that's that's not a thing that bucket
will be ripped from the post exactly but
because i'm so sorry i appreciate that
but
it was hard and i was honest about that
valentine val's very good at being like
you need to like be don't just i'll i'll
candy coat the whole thing be like it
was actually great here's why you know
but like you notice these feelings of
whatever it might be dread or
disappointment and then now we we let
them in and we have tea with those bad
feelings and it's okay that's what sort
of uh doesn't charge them up the pushing
them away charges them up but if you let
them in like little rambunctious
children oh here's sadness come on in
give him a hug tussle his hair
it's much better that way to say yes to
these bad feelings so that was a great
technique oh i i feel sad yes thank you
sadness all right right your brain has
no idea what the [__] to do with that
it's like he's saying thank you for the
sadness like it
it it takes away its charge yeah
but we did mourn it
and then i i am happy to say that there
was this like oh my god i'm writing i'm
all these ideas but but not just
inspiration like life energy like prana
i was like ah i'm alive
and like when you when you know what
you're doing and your future is sort of
has the illusion of being guaranteed
like season two that's someone saying
like here's what your 2023 will be and
you're like ah that seems nice but
you're not
busting with electricity that's that's
actually more like a coast yeah the
plane is in the air and now it's just
going to coast and and glide on the air
it's actually it can be more exciting i
said on we made it weird
it's like i was a pirate and i docked
and i got off and i opened a spice shop
and it was doing really well and then
one day someone said you don't have a
permit for these spices and i was like
all right and i got back on the boat and
then and then to make it even funnier
another pirate ship started shooting me
with cannon balls and my ship that's the
show it's now deteriorating all spices
are in the water but the cool thing is
you get to grab a rope put a knife in
your teeth and swing to the other boat
yes and you go ah and you would never do
that no pirate did that unless he had to
and later in that pirate's one-legged
life he was like remember that time i
put a knife and swung on a rope that was
some insane [__]
that really shivered me timber
but he wouldn't have done it unless his
ship was being bombarded with
cannonballs and it becomes his best
story i love it i love it the uh
my favor i think it's i'll say the
superlative i think it's the most useful
quote that i say to myself in my life
it's uh life has many chapters
like it's just like another way of
saying this you don't have to pretend
it's profound it's just like no i like
it but it's just like you have the
chapter where you did this thing wow
you know it's not it's just but it's
like it's just like it's very it's so
deep and simple it's just like yeah
there's a time while you do this if it's
it's basically like another way to say
um this too shall pass it's like it's
basically like have you read deep and
symbol
oh no it's steep and simple mr rogers
favorite book well i know i know the
quote that's where i get the quote from
from mr rogers
oh i didn't know it was from someone is
it from that guy in like hawaii that he
was someone wrote a book called deep and
simple
i read it because it's fred's favorite
book yes i liked howard are you mr
rogerson i love myself okay he's like my
hero he's mentioned in the book he's
mentioned in the speech yeah i know and
he was one of he's like david maybe i
just like these show hosts
but like well there's something mr
rogers very similar where else athletics
uh tv shows you're going to see
commitment like writ large look
everyone understands yeah because i
can't just be like oh my math teacher or
something exactly you you don't know her
or something yeah exactly it has to be
someone we all know and i was thinking
about how i really the moment that like
really crystallized it was when i was
like
mr rogers walking into the studio in
pittsburgh
for his 848th episode yeah and today
it's about
you know today it's about how buddy you
need first you know where you need to
walk places or drive places or something
it's like stuff like something he's like
running out of concepts to teach kids
that is how it is on daniel tiger's
neighborhood we laugh about it all the
time the first season it's like sharing
makes you feel so good
season 10 is like if someone waves at
you and they weren't waving at you
they're behind you like it's they run
out of stuff pretty quick i used to
think about arthur moral quandaries
you know every arthur episode is a moral
quandary that they and they're very
simple season one but it was the longest
running cartoon after the simpsons whoa
and by like the 23rd you read the
episode descriptions
if it's okay to reuse flaws yeah yeah
it's like francine said this to muffy
but then muffy said this back and arthur
wonders if it was okay for francine to
do that given that muffy was having a
hard day but francine also recently had
a thing yeah it's like arthur buster
will untangle
wow this uh r slash relationships
question or something do you remember
your question
i guess my question was about stand up
and i guess it applies to this recent
news in your life do you see
your life as corpus or opus is it like
i'm trying to make the great the great
american joke or something or is it like
i am part of a show called pete holmes
that i'm committed to and all of these
shows and all of the stand up i'll tell
you and how do you think about
commitment with regard to that because
well it's another conan quote coming at
you hot and you'll know the answer there
is is he was like when like the tonight
show went away and all these things he
was like i look at my life like a mosaic
a mosaic obviously is art made with
these little tiles and he's like
sometimes you get a black tile
and you but you put it down and you
don't understand what's happening
sometimes you get like six seven eight
black dark gray puke green
these nasty colors you wanted the shiny
blues and the brilliant whites and
whatever it might be think those are the
light colors you're getting all these
dark ones and what is it and then at the
end of your career you stand back and
you go like
the dark ones created the contrast like
they are what made
bad defines good they're the science
they say now i'm going to another
metaphor but same coin different size
yeah
this is okay here's a weird on uh on on
in the news hollywood question sure
about that exact thing
do you think will smith
maybe this is too close to home i don't
know do you think i did tell you i
auditioned for king rooney
but it's like i think that makes me and
will pretty tough
but yeah we don't need to say it's just
like in the abstract the proverbial will
smith yeah he wins the oscar being a
perfect person his whole life yeah and
then he has to have the like anime of
like i've done everything or
he has this wrench thrown into his life
right before the moment
do you wonder if like is there more pain
and just like having the perfect
the perfect life or is there more um
pain in like having the wrench thrown in
your life because it's the mosaic thing
like because yeah 10 years from now when
he decides how he wants to come back
from this exactly that will be like the
the flavor in his life look it's i'm not
saying it's good or bad that he did it i
don't want to like make light of
whatever it was but like
looking at lives it's just such a story
of a life that's what i
i think you know where i stand we
started talking about paraplegics it's
like these things that you wouldn't ask
for often end up being yeah exactly what
makes the thing a work of art at the end
and that weird
twilight zone
ambro all you eat is ambrosia and
everything's perfect
everything goes your way
like the it's in the matrix where
they're like you know the first matrix
there was no suffering yeah because the
machines thought like machines and they
were like well we just need them to be
comatose let's make it no suffering but
they were like we lost whole batches of
people because they couldn't accept it
it's like we know
that it has to be
the bad night at the oscars to inform
the the good night at the or the good
life for the black and the way you need
both they define one another yeah like
when he comes back in five years and
gives this beautiful like or not or not
you know who knows it's michael you're
only losing losing yeah
yeah you have to go you have to play
baseball sometimes or whatever i'm not
being the millionth person to make fun
of that yeah i'm saying it needs to be
this yes this defines this yes that's it
that's the whole thing of life all right
we figured it out yes
um
let's do a couple random questions
before we get to the um meaning of life
have you ever seen a ghost you seem like
you haven't
i have not seen a ghost but i'm a
believer really i'm a believer by the
way i didn't mean that as an insult like
you just seemed like too happy
i used to have a joke about seeing a
ghost jelly um
you know if i ever saw a ghost
my first response would be like oh my
gosh there's an afterlife wow
i'm not i'm scared and i don't get why
all the people get that oh okay
oh my gosh because he i i don't want to
say exactly but he was like it would
shake his world view
yeah oh my god my first thought wouldn't
be like yeah oh my gosh i'm in danger it
would be like the most important
question in human history it's like has
a new piece of data yeah that's right i
think it when when it becomes not
someone from our plane who died and is
now still inhabiting the castle that
they lived in when it becomes a little
glimpse into the fact that there may be
like an infinite potentially number of
realities over lane and one of them just
sort of blooped like just for a second
that's less uh me serving yeah you know
what i mean i'm like if i'm like oh i'll
die and i'll be a ghost that's good but
if it's just like for no reason just
like a sponge with a tongue comes
through the wall
okay
that's fair
um but yeah i i love that no ghost have
you ever almost died
no no i've had a pretty okay sorry
when's the last time you [__] your pants
it's like you know i wish i'd almost
died then i could talk about it
yeah if you don't have that one you
gotta talk about poopy pants any good
poop pants stories no bad poop pants
stories
um
i you know i have i did in high school
that was really bad yeah i did a bad one
in computer science class oh no and i
was like i was a good kid in school and
like i didn't and i i just i made the
right decision i said i'm going to get
up and leave and whatever the teacher
says i'm just not going to listen and
not comment and not say anything that's
the way to do it she says you can't go
and i just was like i'm going
what did you eat something wrong what
happened you just got a little i don't
ever remember
don't be embarrassed the last time i did
was i was trying to get online to look
at pornography the night before my
college roommate showed up and i did it
for so long that i was like i can make
it i can make it i can make it that's
what i don't know i did not make it and
i logged on and i didn't log on i
couldn't get online you know i was
hardcore i made this my recommendation
for anyone who has this in high school i
came back
and i totally owned it to the two guys
that were next to me you were like i
just yeah i just yeah i just i just
moved my pants because here we are this
is why i'm asking this becomes the good
story you were just like hey guess what
what's up i just [__] my pants and
they're like oh okay like that's why i
left that's what happened i threw the i
threw away the boxes on the trash can
we'll see who's laughing when i'm giving
this speech at harvard [__]
[Laughter]
i love that i'm trying to think uh oh
well that's the question we'll get to at
the end um we've been i feel like we've
been talking about the meaning of life
this entire podcast yes
no no no in the best way usually in the
last 30 we're like let's talk about the
meaning of life
but but uh in the interest of time
we'll just do it briefly you mentioned
richard rohr you mentioned half jewish
half catholic
what just
do you have any framework for the
meaning of life any symbol system yeah
any tradition that speaks to you
i have i have two
ideas that
have sung a song in my heart so yeah
what do i know about the meaning of life
but like i could tell you about the deep
songs in my heart hit him
one
and and the the
i came at them because i'm just like
very you can probably tell i like start
from the abstract on down stars down to
soil instead of soil up to stars but i
could starve for the sars down to the
soil but
you know i have these two ideas that i'm
like fighting for in my public life
which are democracy and solidarity
but there's like a core concrete thing
inside of each of those so what's the
thing inside of democracy
the thing is that democracy in my in my
heart is like creativity there's some
spiritual thing
about the fact that the world presents
us with something and we come up with
something else
um and there's this amazing philosopher
roberto unger who says there's more in
us
in each of us individual he has these
grand quotes there is more in us in each
of us individually and in all of us
collectively than there ever is in the
world
and the act of creation is the act of
turning the tables on the world the
world gives you a script it tries to
code a machine in your head but inside
your head is also an anti-machine called
the imagination this is all it's just
the whole quote yeah no no i stopped the
quote and then just did some summaries
after that that was inside
an anti-machine called the imagination
where the new is created and i just
think there's there's something amazing
there's something really special so
that's him like putting words in a thing
i just felt deeper than words which is
i just love the idea that people have
ideas and i just love it i think
everybody has ideas and what i say the
project of democracy is the project
democracy is society admitting that
everyone has ideas everyone can
co-create our shared world and so i
really believe in the like spiritual
project of respecting the gifts that you
were given as your ideas and oh my gosh
i've been given a gift from the spirit
world it's an idea or it's a thing and
now i if i find it to be authentic and
true i have to do the labor of bringing
it into the world by painting the
painting you know yeah the idea comes to
you and if you say no it'll go to
somewhere you go to someone and it's
like oh gosh and then and i have to
carry this yes and
then you do the work of that and then
the project in society is the project of
saying all the people no matter their
background no matter where they're from
no matter where they are they have the
the spirit realm doesn't care
like who they are in all the structures
of our world the ideas will come to them
too so that's one so that's democracy
solidarity
is um
the core thing of that is like the
unprofound thing of love it's that if if
if the creation stuff is we want to help
everyone achieve their dreams or realize
their dreams this is about seeing each
other's dreams as our own it's like the
martin luther king stuff of we're all
bound in a in a in a single garment of
humanity we're all trying the catholic
stuff of uh
of
i love this quote from father james f
keenan i have like my little hero
intellectual heroes of all the different
parts of it that have put words on
whatever what i felt he said mercy
is the willingness to enter into the
chaos of others
and he's like that's what god did with
jesus is he said oh i'm in comfort
there's a lot of chaos down there i'm
gonna the message of christianity is god
entered into the chaos of humanity and
what we have to do what usually our sin
is is not like i drank when i said i
want drink or something our sin is the
failure to bother to love and love is
willingness to enter into the chaos of
others oh i have comfort but someone's
having a really chaotic thing over there
i'm going to jump in i'm going to jump
in like god jumped into us
you know and not that we're god but that
like we'll act as as
as he did and and
in doing that in caring and extending
mercy to each other the catholics have
this like phrase the works of mercy
where they said okay if you don't know
what we mean by that i'm gonna lay it
out there
feed feed the hungry give drink to the
thirsty you know um uh clothe the naked
visit the imprisoned visit the sick you
know bury the dead um
uh what you do in caring for each other
in being merciful to each other is you
weave us all together you start
re-knitting the stuff that you repair
the breach you bridge the divides you
bring the outside in and the inside out
you know and um
and weave together the garment again so
so that's the work of solidarity and so
those are my those are my two was that
too what a stupid answer my word my
worry was
what are you crazy
it's fantastic oh yeah who was that
quote which which one i don't know the
big one
[__] happens who said that
his name is roberto hunger roberto unger
this this you have to text me a
visionary brazilian american oh wow
yeah fantastic answer do you think when
we die it's over dead over
i'm uh i'm uh no i'm a no and then i
think we got i think we got something
really i don't know though i don't i fun
can i tell you i don't know i hate to
say this but i was like harvard boy
computer science he's probably like can
turn the computer off no no
i love it look at you um and i don't
know you know this is such a stupid
thought um
i i tell myself i literally i'm gonna
try to be honest and fall over here i
literally say
in my 40s i'll think about that
yeah i'm like not ready to think about
it too hard now by the way maybe i
should but and i've scheduled for myself
i said like i've like set a reminder
start thinking about what's in the
afterlife yes you know start reading the
traditions of that they're like feeling
that um
in i believe it's indian it is indian
culture i just don't want to be wrong
but i'm going to risk being wrong ramdas
talked about in indian culture it was
like
uh you got your teenagers then you got
your 20s and 30s to like build your
career and and 30s to have your family
and then it's like 40s 50s i might be
getting the decades wrong then what we
call retirement
is when you're supposed to double like
dig in deep to the meaning of it all
yeah like you play that you dance the
dance yeah and then in your golden years
you go like okay now what was all that
it's like after the fact yeah but like
there's something beautifully respectful
of that it's like i'm going to just
dance the dance and then i'll go who's
playing that music where was i just want
to like sit in the
the i just want to sit with the the
mundane stuff you're mundane and like
earthly in the deep sense of the word
mundane like like we're all here and we
all love each other and we do fun things
and we make crafts and we love places
and we
we go sit on this couch and you know i
don't want to
i'm just not i'm not ready for that yet
i haven't i haven't circled in the
circle of uh
circling here and back to the that depth
yet i love it but my inkling my heart my
heart is open to the the light there the
light at the end of the funnel there
rhombus also used to say i want to
believe things that would make other
people's hair turn white
like he wanted to
soften
to the infinite potentials like and i
think there's something really admirable
about that we we went back to like
believing in that that there might be a
time for gay rights you know is one type
of belief then i think there's a
spiritual or cosmic equivalent to that
being like start playing with those
thought experiments and getting soft
it's it's fun and spacious yes it's
really fun well i i can't wait for you
what is this what did you get me should
i i got you a gift it's kind of um
it's a book i know you like these books
that reflect on deep meaning
and i thought you'd like this one maybe
you
maybe you have it already have you ever
read this one no okay the gift by lewis
hyde you know when i was talking about
the imagination and the gifts and the
stuff and the gilbert stuff yeah this
book is one of the two books that
changed my life really the other one was
i am now by martin buber okay uh the
great one on like how to really bring
people this one is the um this is a
sorry great rap job sorry
i heard you martin but i mean like
ribbon i just took it off like it was a
rapper around the mcdonald's number two
no that was great this is part of my joy
of seeing this as an end in itself
instead of a means i'm like oh you know
we're seeing a person i'm meeting him
i'm going to this house
i got to bring him a gift
what this is about is um
it's about uh the difference between
give my dad was a cultural
anthropologist
um everything makes sense now if i'm
like in total stuff he was like and um
so it's a very anthropological book it's
like about the difference between gift
cultures and exchange cultures so it
starts with this like little like
you can have an exchange culture where i
get something and you get something or
you can have this gift culture where
like the gift flows between all of us oh
my god but then it just like starts
expanding out and expanding out and it's
like what about the gift of the artist's
gift and what about like the gift of the
history of judaism and christianity and
what about like uh like the gift that
walt whitman wrote about and then it
smiles out and then you start seeing the
whole world in terms of the gift wow and
um all these artists love it and i know
you're you're you're you're on a
creative journey and i thought you did
thank you so much pete i really
appreciate that and it sounds a lot
lighter than the jason bateman movie the
gift which is about
i i don't even want to spoil it did you
see it
oh no that was the movie version of oh
really well that was very dark
i don't even want to spoil that but this
is the novelization
it was after the fact i love when they
write him like the first batman they
wrote the book after the movie
and i read it thank you so much yes well
we've done it all
i love this episode thank you so much
for coming thank you for having me on i
so appreciate it my sincere i you know
i'm uh
i i will say i'm a fan of the podcast
and i am one of the
parasocial listeners that you've been
committed to and being out every
wednesday on the podcast that's right
and so it's so wonderful show up on
wednesday
i don't think we've missed a while have
we ever missed a wednesday
friday's ones sometimes come out late
but the wednesday ones i don't think
we've ever missed a wednesday
i think i remember it
i remember that one
margaret joe
margaret has that why did i pick one of
the few people that hasn't on the
podcast
um thank you so much
the last question as you know is can you
tell me a time that you laughed really
really hard in your life any guess
where maybe you were little maybe
someone fell down maybe [__] your pants
in computer science class can you laugh
it doesn't even have to be a good story
but like i just like giving you the
chance to have the memory if tears are
streaming down your face
and you just can't stop laughing how old
are you who are you with what are you
doing
um one of the great loves of my life
is my high school friends i've had these
high school friends my whole life
every time we get together it's just
constant
comedy jazz the whole time it's there's
no serious conversation it's just bits
bits bits bits bits
and um
and there's this one there's the great
bit
that is like the legendary bit among our
friends what is it it's called sugar
bear
oh i know sugar berries oh yeah sugar
berry okay yeah you guys have a sugar
bear yeah everybody has a shirt the
sugar bears tell me sugar okay matt
guertson plays sugar bear i
know sugar bear is some woodland figure
i don't know how it came out in our
sergeant mayor some woodland figure he
just like is a man of the cecil woodsman
the man yes this is man of the woods
it's got a bear
sugar his name is sugar bear
and the rest of us
i don't know how this happened it's just
a rise a rose and everyone it's the
undisputed goat of all of our bits like
we can name like we sometimes play a
game of like bits back and forth if we
can name somebody yes it's on this
weekend sugar bears this woodsman he
kind of mumbles
but
all the rest of us are his press team
and we are just always
um we're all uh accounting for sugar
bear
so so we we come we start out and we go
we go uh you know sugar bear sugar bear
is a very learned man but you know he
doesn't learn from books
and then and then gerson would come and
he was like
yeah
and then and then we'd be like don't
worry sugar bear sugar bear has seven
wives or something
like sugar bear
sugar bear
sugar bears are kids most of it is
saying sugar bear i feel like it's just
fun sugar bear is a king to many men
it's like we're slowly building the
story of him and then he pops in and
then goes
and we'll just we could do it we could i
could let you know if you wanna if
anyone wants to do this at home you can
do it for seven hours i want to do it
sugar bear declines free haircut this is
just something you need to know either
sugar banana that's what you do you got
your clyde's free haircut sugar bear
likes to do that himself
it's just it's like like what was that
barbing star where they're like talking
about the fictional
uh character i forget what it is but
they show up at the spoiler they show up
at the end we all watch that during the
pandemic it's okay i love that it sounds
like you have rich good deep friends i
love them yeah and you've committed to
them yes in your poc i'll never forget
the the the
nail and the pot the bucket with the i
i've already forgotten it
um thank you the book is called
dedicate your life change your life
right
it's close
dedicated
and uh and it's not by pete davidson
it's by peter davis yes the one time you
are googlable so you google pete davis
and then you click did you mean pete
davis because it will automatically say
that's right yeah we want to get you to
the point where you if you google pete
davidson that's my goal so that is my
north star obviously you meant pete
davis one day yeah the guy who's gonna
think about spirituality in his 40s that
guy right
yeah or not or not well thank you so
much would you grace us with a keeper
crispy would you say keep it oh yes oh
my gosh it's an honor
keep it crispy you keep it crispy thanks
man
great i love it
[Music]